WANT TO START BY WELCOMING ALL
OF YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE HEARING ON THE BALLOT
MEASURE NUMBER EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
NINE AMENDING CONSUMER PRIVACY
LAWS TO START ELECTED I THINK
ALL OF THE STAFF WHO HAVE MADE
OUR RETURN TO THE CAPITAL
POSSIBLE THIS INCLUDES STAFF
FROM ASSEMBLY RUSE THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTSAND THE LEGISLATIVE
DATACENTER WHO PUT IN COUNTLESS
HOURS PROCURING AND CONFIGURING
THE NEW EQUIPMENT AND
TECHNOLOGY TO MAXIMIZE
PARTICIPATION IN OUR HEARINGS.
TO THAT ND I WILL NOW SHARE A
FEW NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS
OF OUR HEARING TODAY REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION TO HELP
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE AND TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE
HEARING ROOM AND THE CAPITAL SO
WE ARE ONLY TO HELP LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCHED AGAIN
A HEARING IN PERSON. IN WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE DELAY MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA. SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE LATER
ON. I WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU
CAN ALSO EXIT THE HEARING BONE
ONCE YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING
WILL RETURN TO YOUR OWN SEAT.
PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING OUR ELEVATOR USED TO
ONE PERSON AT A TIME. WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
WITNESSES MAY TESTIFY THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND ISN'T NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY THE COMMITTEE-
WHAT'S- ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING AND PLEASE CALL
IN EARLY TO ACCOMMODATE ANY
DELAYS IN THE SYSTEM AND ALSO
TO ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE INCLUDING MEETING THE
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN ANY
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE NOISE
DISTORTION. THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE.
YOU CAN ALSO CALL THE COMMUNITY
AT. NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
TWO TWO ZERO ZERO IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE AT FULL SERVICE. AND
MY STAFF WOULD TRY TO HELP OUT.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US-
WE IMPLEMENT- METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. WITH THAT I WILL NOW TURN
TO THE MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
PASSED THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
CONSUMER PRIVACY LAW IN THE
NATION. NAMELY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT OR THE
CCPA WHICH BROUGHT LE GIVES
CONSUMERS TO RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
INFORMATION COMPANIES COLLECT
ABOUT THEM. THE RIGHT TO OPT
OUT OF THE SALE OF THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION AND THE
RIGHT TO HAVE THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION DELETED. AMONG
OTHER THINGS. THE CITY PA
REPRESENTS A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN A LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE MANY OF WHOM ARE HERE IN
THE ROOM TODAY. IT STARTED OUT
AS A BALLOT INITIATIVE PROPOSED
BY MISTER ALISTAIR MAKE
TAGGERT. WHICH ULTIMATELY
BECAME AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE CO
AUTHOR BY MYSELF SENATOR
HERTZBERG HAS SENATOR DOT. THE
BALLOT INITIATIVE BEFORE US
TODAY TO SEE P. R. E. A. WOULD
AMEND THE CCPA IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS INCLUDING. BY
INCORPORATING THE CONCEPT OF
DATA MINIMIZATION. BY REQUIRING
THAT ANY SUBSEQUENT LAWS PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE THAT AMEND
THE ACT TO BE IN FURTHERANCE OF
PRIVACY OR OTHERWISE BE
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS. AND BY
CREATING A PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY IN STATE GOVERNMENT TO
ENFORCE THESE LAWS AND MANY OF
THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS PUT IN
PLACE BY THE CCP ACT. I WILL GO
INTO MORE DETAILS ABOUT THE
MEASURE ANYMORE AT THIS POINT.
AND THAT'S OF ALL PANEL SIDE
HERE TO DO BUT I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT WHAT I SEE THE MAIN
OBJECTIVE FOR THIS HERE. UNLIKE
LEGISLATIVE BILLS WHICH GO
THROUGH A NUMBER OF PUBLIC
HEARINGS BALLOT INITIATIVES DO
NOT ALWAYS ENJOY THE SAME
DEGREE OF PUBLIC DEBATE. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A STATUTORY
OBLIGATION PURSUANT TO SECTION
NINE ZERO THREE FOUR OF THE
ELECTIONS CO TO HOLD JOINT
HEARINGS ON INITIATIVES. THAT
HAVE OBTAINED 25% OF THE NUMBER
OF SIGNATURES REQUIRED. TO
QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT. IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR ALL THIS
COMMITTEE WAS INFORMED THAT THE
INITIAL HIT THE 25% THRESHOLD.
AND WE ARE THEREFORE REQUIRED
TO HOLD A HEARING AT LEAST ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE DAYS BEFORE
THE ELECTION OR BY JUNE TWENTY
FIFTH. WHY PUBLIC DEBATE ON
THESE MEASURES IS ALWAYS
IMPORTANT IT IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL ON A MEASURE ASK
COMPREHENSIVE AND COMPLEX AS
THIS ONE. AS OUR PANELISTS A WE
SPEAK TODAY I AM PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN THE PRACTICAL
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
PROPOSED INITIATIVE AND THE
CCPA IN TERMS OF THE EFFECT ON
CONSUMER PRIVACY AND
WORKABILITY FOR BUSINESS. THIS
IS. I WAS SEE WHAT CLEAR AS A
CONCEPT OFTEN BECOMES
COMPLICATED AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER. I HOPE THIS HEARING CAN
BE A VALUABLE TOOL TO VOTERS
WISHING TO MAKE AN EDUCATED
DECISION ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
INITIATIVE GOAL INTO THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION. MY CONCERN
IS ALWAYS. IS TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF CALIFORNIANS AND
IT'S AWFUL MANNER THAT- CO
EXIST WITH OTHER RIGHTS
AFFORDED TO THE STATIONS%
RESIDENTS THE NEED FOR THIS
PROTECTION HAS BEEN AMPLIFIED
BY THE CURRENT PANDEMIC AND
PROTEST AS WE SEE CIVIL
LIBERTIES BEING COMPROMISED ON
A NUMBER OF FRONTS AND WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME THE STATE ENTERS
AND I'M PRESIDENT OF FISCAL
CRISIS CAUSING CUTS TOO MANY OF
OUR VITAL SOCIAL SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. TO THAT END I WILL BE
ASKING AND I DO ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUE SO MANY OF WHOM WILL
BE JOINING US LATER TO ASK
QUESTIONS TO THE VARIOUS
PANELISTS TESTIFYING HERE TODAY.
SO SINCE I DON'T SEE ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES I THINK I'M GONNA
RESERVE MIGHT. OUR COMMENTS FOR
MY COLLEAGUES LATER ON. AND UP
AT THIS TIME- I LIKE TO START
WITH OUR FIRST PANEL. AND OUT-
TODAY WE HOW FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
MISS AND NEED A LEAD. I BELIEVE
SHE'S ON VIDEO TODAY. TO HELP
US TESTIFIED SO IT THIS TIME
LET US. THE. TURN TO MISLI. I
THINK I SAW HER IN NATURE A BIT
EARLIER SO WE'LL SEE. WELL WE
ARE FIGURING OUT THE TECHNOLOGY
I NOTICED THAT SENATOR DODD
HAS- CHINA'S SO I WANT TO
WELCOME HIM. AND I MAY EVEN
INVITE HIM TO MAKE SOME OPENING
REMARKS IF HE SO DESIRES WE TRY
TO FIGURE OUT THE THE VIDEO AT
THIS POINT SENATOR DOT TO.
WELCOME WELCOME TO OUR HEARING
TODAY. RECEIVE YOUR OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS A- GRAHAM NORTON YEAH
YOUR TOPIC FOR ME POLICY AREA
FOR ME AND- FOR THE LEGISLATURE
I THINK FOR THE PEOPLE THE
STATE THE CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
AND- SO SORRY THAT. WE ARE IN
THE SITUATION WE'RE IN
EVERYBODY'S GOT TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE- O HERE IN
THE CAPITAL BUT WE'LL GET
THROUGH IT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US AGAIN.
GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR I CAN YOU
HEAR ME HI YES WE COULD HEAR
YOU ALL I COULD WE COULD SEE
YOU NOW OH OKAY GREAT THINK
HUNKA MISLI. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
WERE OR ALL ADAPTING TO THIS I
NEW TECHNOLOGY SO- VERY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- ANNUALLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING
US TO PARTICIPATE IN YOUR
HEARING TODAY- WE WILL BE
PROVIDING AND REVIEW. THE
PROPOSED CHANGES MADE BY THIS
MEASURE AS WELL AS THE FISCAL
IMPACTS IT COULD HAVE. WE WILL
BE USING THE HANDOUT WHICH I
BELIEVE HAS BEEN PROVIDED TO
YOU IN YOUR PACKETS- AS A GUIDE
FOR COMMENTS IT IS ALSO
AVAILABLE ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AS WELL AS THE ONLY A
WEBSITE. IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
ONE OF YOUR HAND OUT WE FIRST
LET'S START OFF WITH THE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE ALLEY
ROLL LA ROLE IN THE PROCESS-
BEFORE INITIATIVES CAN GO OUT
TO BE CIRCULATED FOR
SIGNATURES. STATE LAW REQUIRES
THAT OUR OFFICE WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PREPARE A JOINT IMPARTIAL
FISCAL ANALYSIS ON THE
INITIATIVE AND IT DOES INCLUDE
AND ESTIMATES OF THE FISCAL
IMPACTS I COULD HAVE ON THE
STATE. AND LOCAL GOVENMENTS. A
SUMMARY OF THOSE FISCAL OF
FACTS ARE THEN INCLUDED WITH
THE POSITION THAT CIRCULATED
FOR SIGNATURE. FOR THOSE
INITIATIVES THAT COLLECT
SUFFICIENT SIGNATURES ON THE
QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT. STATE
LAW REQUIRES THAT OUR OFFICE
PROVIDE IMPARTIAL ANALYSES OF
ALL OF THEM AND THEY ARE
INCLUDED IN THE STATEWIDE VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDE AND IT DOES
INCLUDE A DESCRIPTION OF THE
MEASURE AS WELL. AS AN OVERVIEW
OF ITS FISCAL A FAX. AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
PREPARING THOSE MATERIALS FOR
THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
BALLOTS. IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
TWO OF YOUR HAND OUT- WE WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT SOME KEY POINTS OF
BACKGROUND IN OF EXISTING LAW.
THAT ARE TOUCHED ON BY THE
MEASURE SO AT THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL AWARE OF- BUSINESSES
COLLECT. DATA FROM VARIOUS
SOURCES AND USE IT FOR VARIOUS
PURPOSES. CERTAIN BUSINESSES
THAT OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA AND
COLLECT PERSONAL DATA SUCH AS
MEANS AN INTERNET ACTIVITY ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH CERTAIN
DATA PRIVACY REQUIREMENTS.
THESE ARE GENERALLY BUSINESS
SAYS THAT EARN MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IN ANNUAL REVENUE.
THAT BUY SELL OR SHARE FOR
COMMERCIAL PURPOSES THE
PERSONAL DATA A FIFTY THOUSAND
OR MORE CONSUMERS HOUSEHOLDS
FOR DEVICES ANNUALLY. OR THAT
AND 15% OR MORE OF THEIR ANNUAL
REVENUES FROM SELLING PERSONAL
DATA. AS I MENTIONED THERE
REQUIRED TO- MEET SPECIFIC DATA
PRIVACY REQUIREMENTS FOR
EXAMPLE BUSINESSES ARE
GENERALLY REQUIRED TO TELL
CONSUMERS IF THEY COLLECT OR
SELL PERSONAL DATA AND WHAT
THEY'LL USE THAT FOR. THEIR
ALSO REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH
CERTAIN PRIVACY RIGHTS SUCH AS
ALLOWING CONSUMERS TO REQUEST
FREE REPORTS ON THE PERSONAL
DATA THAT IS COLLECTED AND SOLD
BY THE BUSINESS ABOUT THEM.
RUMORS ARE ASO ABLE TO TELL
BUSINESSES TO DELETE OR TEN NOT
SELL THEIR PERSONAL DATA. FOR
THOSE CONSUMERS WHO CHOOSE TO
MAKE USE OF THOSE RIGHTS
BUSINESSES ARE PROHIBITED FROM
TREATING THEM DIFFERENTLY SUCH
AS CHARGING THEM A DIFFERENT
PRICE TO PROVIDING A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF SERVICE. IF THE
BUSINESS FAILS TO ADDRESS A
VIOLATION OF ANY OF THE DATA
PRIVACY REQUIREMENTS WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS CALIFORNIA DOJ THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CAN SEEK
PENALTIES OF UP TO TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER VIOLATION
OR UP TO SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. PER INTENTIONAL
VIOLATION. THE PENALTY REVENUES
ARE DEPOSITED INTO THE STATE'S
CONSUMER PRIVACY FUNDS. AND
IT'S TO FIRST BE USED TO OFFSET
STATE COURT IN THE OJ COSTS
RELATED TO ENFORCING THESE LAWS
BEFORE THEY CAN BE USED FOR ANY
OTHER PURPOSE AS DESIGNATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE. TURNING TO
PAGE THREE OF YOUR HANDS OUT.
BUSINESSES ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO
MEET DATA BREACH REQUIREMENTS
THIS INCLUDES TAKING REASONABLE
STEPS TO PROTECT CONSUMER AND-
MISSION AS WELL AS INFORMING
PEOPLE IF THEIR DATA WAS ACCESS
IN A BREACH. AGES OF CERTAIN
PERSONAL INFORMATION CAN RESULT
IN PENALTIES OF ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS PER CONSUMER PER
EVENT OR ACTUAL DAMAGES
WHICHEVER IS GREATER. A
CONSUMER THAT'S AFFECTED BY
THIS TYPE OF REACH CAN SEEK
THESE PENALTIES IF THE BUSINESS
FAILS TO ADDRESS THE VIOLATION
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS DOJ IS ALSO
ABLE TO SEEKPENALTIES AND THEN
SOME OF THIS PENALTY REVENUE
COULD BE DEPOSITED INTO THE
CONSUMER PRIVACY FOUGHT. AT A
HIGH LEVEL CALIFORNIA DOJ IS
GENERALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENFORCING CONSUMER PRIVACY- AND
DATA BREACH LAWS AND REALLY DO
THIS IN TWO WAYS- ONE WAY IS TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF REGULAR
REGULATIONS- TO PROVIDE
BUSINESSES CONSUMER GUIDE HOW
TO COMPLY. BUT ALSO- BY FILING
LAWSUITS INTRO CHORDS ARE
PROSECUTING CRIMES IN THE AREA.
TURNING TO PAGE HAND OUT WE'RE
GOING TO TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
THE PROPOSAL A NUMBER OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE PROPOSAL TAKE
A FACT IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE BUT THERE ARE FEW
COMPONENTS SUCH AS THE CREATION
OF THE NEW AGENCY WHICH I'LL
TALK ABOUT SHORTLY I WOULD GO
INTO EFFECT UPON VOTER APPROVAL.
THE CHANGES ARE MADE BY THIS
PROPOSED MEASURE REALLY FALL
INTO FOUR KEY AREA. THE FIRST
IS THAT IT CHANGES EXISTING
CONSUMER DATA PRIVACY LAWS AND
IT DOES SO IN A COUPLE WAYS. IT
CHANGES BUSINESSES I NEED TO
COMPLY WITH THESE LAWS SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN SOME CASES CERTAIN
BUSINESS. I KNOW WHAT YOU TO
COMPLY- FOR EXAMPLE BUSINESSES
THAT BUY OR SELL PERSONAL DATA
OF BETWEEN. FIFTY THOUSAND TO
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND CONSUMERS
FOR HOUSEHOLD ANNUALLY WHEN I
WANT TO COMPLY IN OTHER CASES
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT AT YOUR
BUSINESS MAY NEED TO COME. IT
ALSO EXPANDS EXISTING CONSUMER
DATA PRIVACY REQUIREMENTS SUCH
AS REQUIRING NOTIFICATION TO
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES SHARE
DATA. BUT IT ALSO EASES
REQUIREMENTS OF CERTAIN
BUSINESSES- SO CERTAIN
BUSINESSES WOULD BE ABLE TO NOT
COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
UNDER VERY SPECIFIC CONDITIONS
SO FOR EXAMPLE- BUSINESSES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO DELETE STUDENT
GRADES ARE EDUCATIONAL. DATA
THE SECOND MAJOR AREA OF
CHANGES THAT THE PROPOSED
MEASURE WOULD PROVIDE NEW DATA
PRIVACY RIGHTS CONSUMERS WILL
BE ABLE TO DIRECT BUSINESSES TO
NOT SHARE THEIR DATA TO CORRECT
DATA AS WELL AS- TO USE THAT
SENSITIVE DATA SUCH AS SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS- HEALTH DATA
FOR ONLY THE PURPOSE OF
PROVIDING THE REQUESTED GOOD OR
SERVICE. OR FOURTEEN BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS CUSTOMER
SERVICE. THE THIRD AREA IS THAT
THIS PROPOSAL MAKES CHANGES TO
THE EXISTING PENALTY STRUCTURE-
SO FOR EXAMPLE. VIOLATIONS THE
MEASURE AUTHORIZES- A PENALTY
OF UP TO SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR VIOLATIONS
OF MINOR RIGHT. BUT IT ALSO
ELIMINATES THE ABILITY OF
BUSINESSES TO AVOID PENALTIES
BY ADDRESSING VIOLATIONS WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS. ARE TURNING FIVE
OF YOUR HAND OUT IT ALSO LIMITS
THE USE OF CONSUMER PRIVACY
REVENUES FOR PURPOSES OTHER
THAN CONSUMER PRIVACY- SO AFTER
COURT COSTS THE STATE DOJ COSTS
ARE TAKING CARE OF THE MEASURE
WOULD THEN REQUIRE 91% OF THE
RATHER BE INVESTED BY THE STATE.
EARNINGS WERE BE TRANSFERRED TO
THE GENERAL FUND FOR IT USED
FOR OTHER PURPOSES. THE
REMAINING 9% WOULD BE USED TO
SUPPORT PUBLIC EDUCATION
RELATED TO CONSUMER PRIVACY AS
WELL AS TO ADDRESS- FRAUD THAT
RESULTED FROM DATA BREACHES.
THE FOURTH AND FINAL ARIEL WAS
ALREADY REFERENCE BY MISTER
CHAIR- WHICH IS THE NEW MEASURE
CREATES A NEW STATE AGENCY THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY TO OVERSEE AND ENFORCE
THE STATE'S CONSUMER PRIVACY
LAWS. THE NEW AGENCY WOULD HAVE
A VARIETY OF RESPONSIBILITIES
RANGING FROM INVESTIGATING AND
IF YOU CAME VIOLATIONS
ASSESSING PENALTY IS TO
DEVELOPING REGULATIONS THE
AGENCIES DECISIONS RELATED SIT
COMPLAINTS AGAINST BUSINESSES
ARE ASSESSMENTS OF PENALTIES.
WOULD BE- ELIGIBLE FOR REVIEW
BY THE TRIAL COURT. SOME OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE NEW
AGENCY IT WOULD HAVE WOULD BE
SHIFTED FROM DOJ MOST NOTABLY
THE DEVELOPMENT OF REGULATIONS.
HOWEVER DOJ WOULD STILL BE ABLE
TO PROSECUTE CRIMES AND FILE
LAWSUITS AND TRIAL COURTS AND
MOST NOTABLY THIS MEASURE
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT DOJ'S
INVESTIGATION AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES WHAT HAVE PRIORITY
OVER THAT OF THE AGENCY.
TURNING TO THE FINAL PAGE OF
YOUR HAND OUT WE'LL TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO THE FISCAL A FAX.
THIS MEASURE WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE STATE COSTS AS
WELL AS POTENTIALLY ON STATE
AND LOCAL TAX REVENUES. THE
ACTUAL SIZE OF THE IMPACT WILL
REALLY DEPENDS ON HOW CONSUMERS
BUSINESSES AND STATE ND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RESPOND TO THE
MEASURE AND SO IT IS A BIT AND
CERTAIN SO FOR EXAMPLE IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW BUSINESSES WILL
CHANGE THEIR OPERATIONS TO
COMPLY WITH FULL OF THE
PROPOSED MEASURE. AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF VIOLATIONS THAT WILL
BE ASSESSED AND INVESTIGATED
AND EDUCATE. SO WITH THAT IN
MIND WE IDENTIFIED THREE. FAX
THE FIRST IS INCREASED STATE
COSTS FOR THE NEW AGENCY. THE
MEASURE SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES
THAT AT LEAST TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND
BE PROVIDED ANNUALLY IS TO
SUPPORT THE AGENCY'S
OPERATIONS. DEPENDING ON HOW
THE AGENCY CARE OUT ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES. THE ACTUAL
COST COULD POTENTIALLY BE
HIGHER. THE SECOND EFFECT IS
INCREASED STATE DOJ A COURT
COSTS- DOJ WORKLOAD COULD
INCREASE TO THE EXTENT THAT IT
CHOOSES TO INVESTIGATE AND FILE
MORE CASES. SOME OF THIS
INCREASE WORK WHAT LOAD WOULD
BE OFFSET- EITHER PARTIALLY OR
FULLY BY THE SHIFT AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FROM DOJ- TO
THE NEW AGENCY. IN A SIMILAR
WAY COURT WORKLOAD COULD
INCREASE IF MORE CASES ARE
FILED IN COURT. THE COSTS OF
THE INCREASED WORKLOAD WOULD
DEPEND ON THE NUMBER OF
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE
INITIATED AS WELL AS THE TYPES
OF CASES THAT ARE FILED IN THE
QUIRK. IN TOTAL THE STATE COSTS
ARE NOT LIKELY TO EXCEED THE
LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY SOME OR ALL OF THESE
COSTS WOULD BE OFFSET BY THE
INCREASED REVENUES- FROM
HANDLES HE'S- TEST ON
BUSINESSES THAT VIOLATE THE LAW.
THE FINAL AFFECT IS RELATED TO
TAX REVENUES IN THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT OF THEIR- AND SO ON THE
ONE HAND IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
TAX REVENUES COULD DECREASE. SO
FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE COMPLIANCE
COSTS THAT REDUCE BUSINESS
PROFITS THAT COULD RESULT IN A
REDUCTION IN TAX REVENUES.
HOWEVER ON THE OTHER HAND- TAX
REVENUES COULD INCREASE SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF BUSINESSES AND
CONSUMERS LOSE LAST MONEY FROM
LESS SEVERE OR FEWER DATA
BREACHES. IT COULD RESULT IN
CONSUMERS SPENDING MORE ON
TAXABLE GOODS OR BUSINESSES
EARNING WATER AND THAT WOULD
HAVE AN IMPACT TAX REVENUE. THE
TOTAL THAT PACKED HOWEVER IS-
UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME. SO WITH
THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR COMMENTS
WE WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU MISLI FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
ARE WE GONNA HOW FAR QUESTIONS
FOR YOU AT A LATER TIME SO IF I
COULD ASK YOU TO. STAY WITH US-
UNTIL THAT HAPPENS THANK YOU
AGAIN SO NEXT SO- WE'LL HEAR
FROM THE INITIATIVE OF. A
PROPONENT MR ALISTAIR MATAK SO
MISTER MACAQUE. WELCOME THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I MISSED YOUR
AT. BUT FORGET GOING MY LEAD TO
LOWER MY MIGHT ACTUALLY YES
THANK YOU FOR YOURSELF GREAT-
MISSED YOUR UP THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY
NAME CELLS TO RETIRE AND- I'M
THE PROPONENT OF THIS MEASURE
ON THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
I CALIFORNIA FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY. AT THAT BEFORE YOU
GOING HERE IS ONE OF EIGHT-
IT'S JUNE- TWO YEARS AGO WE
WERE WE WERE HERE- AND ALMOST
TWO YEARS AGO IS WHEN- YOU
PASSED THAT TREMENDOUS
LEGISLATION THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT I'M HERE
WITH TWO OF THE AUTHORS AND- I
THINK ONE MORE IS ON THEIR WAY
AND IT'S JUST REALLY A- A AND-
AN HONOR TO BE WITH THE AUTHORS
TO. I THINK AT THE TIME
UNDERSTOOD IT WAS GOING TO BE A
BILL IN. THE YEARS THERE'S
PASSED WE REALIZE WHAT A
ENORMOUS- DEAL IT'S BEEN SINCE
THEN. I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR WORK BACK THEN-
AND- AND SENSE AND THEN I ALSO
JUST BEFORE YOU GO I WANTED TO.
THANK A FEW PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
TODAY. A PART OF MY TEAM WHEN I
SAY WE- I WITH A SMALL TEAM
BUT- BUT GOOD ONE JAMES
HARRISON START TOURNEY- ASHKAN
SOLTANI WAS LET ME COLLECT
PRETTY THE FORMER CHIEF
TECHNOLOGIST OF THE- DC. THE
GOAL OF THIS YEAR. MY WIFE'S
ONLY. WOODEN BE HERE WITH TO
pNOT REGARDING AS CHAIR OF. FIVE
AND A AND YOU COULDN'T ASK FOR
CREATE A OR SOME. MIND TO WORK
SO I WANT THANK ALL THAT. WE
GET GOING. SO TO THE NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO I CAN JUST PUT A
PICTURE OF YOU THAT'S YOU I
MISSED SHARE INTRODUCING THE
LEGISLATION- IN JUNE TWO YEARS
AGO- REMEMBER THE TIME WE WERE
ALL WORRIED ABOUT WHETHER. WHAT
THE VOTES WOULD BE AND IT
TURNED OUT TO BE UNANIMOUS OUT
OF BOTH HOUSES YOU MASTER
FLORENCE HERTZBERG AND- BETTER
DOT THERE'S- AND JUST TO
REFRESH WHAT THE- TCPA DOES IT
GIVES YOU THE RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT INFORMATION IS BEING
COLLECTED ABOUT YOU- THE RIGHT
TO. CONTROL TO SAY NO TO WOULD
SAIL TO DELETE IT. AND YOU TELL
COMPANIES THAT HEY IF YOU'RE
GONNA KEEP. CLICK TO MY
INFORMATION KEEP IT SAFE. THE
NEXT PLEASE. WHAT PEOPLE SAID
WHY NOW YOU KNOW NOW'S NOT THE
TIME FOR ANOTHER INITIATIVE- C.
C. P. A.'S IT'S GETTING
DIGESTED MY ANSWER THE IS THE
OPPOSITE NOW IS EXACTLY THE
RIGHT TIME FOR ANOTHER
INITIATIVE AND THEIR NUMBER
REASONS SO ONE OF THEM IS GOING
TO SEND A STRONG SIGNAL TO
CONGRESS. THE LAST TWO YEARS
ABOUT THE DC A NUMBER OF TIMES
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY
LEGISLATORS FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE OF THE ISLAND BOTH HOUSES
OF TELLING THE SAME STORY. BUT
FOR A QUARTER CENTURY BUSINESS
IS BEEN IN THEIR OFFICE SAYING
DON'T YOU DARE PASSED PRIVACY
LEGISLATION LET US SELF
REGULATION IS THE BEST
REGULATION- YOU'D UNDERSTAND-
THIS COMPLICATED. AND AS SOON
AS CALIFORNIA PASSED ITS LAW
THOSE SAME PEOPLE ARE BACKING
OFF THE SAYING WE NEED
PREEMPTION RIGHT NOW WE NEED TO
NOT HAVE THE SUBJECT IS
CALIFORNIA LAW. AND UNFORTUNATE
ALL OF THE- PROPOSALS OUT OF
THE SEA ARE WOULD BE AS
PROTECTIVE AND A STRONG
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK- THAN
THAT HAVING NINE YOU KNOW
HAVING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. VOTE FOR THIS
NOVEMBER THEY BELIEVE THEY WILL
WE'LL SEND A VERY STRONG
MESSAGE THE CALIFORNIA
DELEGATION IN DC SAYING
WHATEVER YOU DO. DON'T PASS A
LAW THAT'S LESS STRONG IN
CALIFORNIA. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
AT THE AT THE RIGHT TIME TO
ESTABLISH NEW RIGHTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS THAT LOTS HAPPENED
LAST TWO YEARS IN THERE AND
WE'LL GO OVER SOME OF THOSE.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. I MEAN IT'S
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE WORK
ABILITY ISSUES THAT THEY SAID
THAT THIS INITIATIVE WOULD
ADDRESS. AND BY WORK ABILITY I
MEAN AREAS WHERE WE CAN IMPROVE
THE IMPLEMENTATION. MAKE IT
EASIER. AND NOT HURT OR
SOMETIMES IMPROVE PRIVACY THE
SAME TIME. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
AND THEN FINALLY I THINK LOOK
THIS IS IMPORTANT- TO IT TO
COLLEGE. ONE OF THE OPTIONS WE
HAVE HERE IS TO SET A BASELINE
POLICY FOR PRO FOR PRIVACY IN
THE STATE GOING FORWARD. RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A REAL CHAMP IS A
PRIVACY TO THEM IN THIS ROOM.
IN THIS BUILDING IN THIS
LEGISLATURE BUT TERM LIMITS
WILL COME. AND YOU WILL ALWAYS
BE HERE. AND A FUTURE
LEGISLATURE COULD DECIDE TO
UNDO SOMEBODY'S PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS SO WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW TO SUBMIT
THESE GAINS- IN LAW. IN
CALIFORNIA. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
SORT TIMELINE- WE FILED A FIRST
DRAFT SEPTEMBER NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE THEY WE EMBARKED ON A
SEVEN WEEK DISCUSSION WITH- AS
MANY PEOPLE AS WE GET TALKED
ADVOCATES PRIVACY EXPERTS
ACADEMICS REGULATORS BUSINESS
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE- WE HAD
HUNDREDS OF HOURS OF CALLS-
CENTER HERTZBERG WHO'S NOT HERE
WAS- IT INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN
MANY OF THOSE CALLS- AND NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE IN NOVEMBER WE
FILED OUR FINAL VERSION. BACK
BEGAN COLLECTING SIGNATURES IN.
DECEMBER SO LET'S TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE PRIVACY
ENHANCEMENTS CPR A WOULD MAKE
X. PLEASE. SO NEXT ONE OF THE
FIRST IS THIS CREATION OF A
CATEGORY OF SENSITIVE PERSONAL
INFORMATION. NO I STARTED TWO
YEARS AGO I BOUGHT INTO THE
NOTION THAT WE SHOULD TREAT ALL
INFORMATION THE SAME BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT BE WORRIED ABOUT-
YOUR GENDER AND I MIGHT BE
WORRIED ABOUT MY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND SO WE SHOULD
ALTER STREET ALL INFORMATION
THE SAME. IN THE TWO YEARS I'VE
COME TO SEE THAT YOU KNOW AS
SOME JURISDICTIONS DO WE SHOULD
I SHOULD PROBABLY HAVE THIS
SPECIAL CATEGORY OF SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION IT'S SO
SENSITIVE YOUR HEALTH. YOUR
FINANCIAL INFORMATION YOUR YOUR
SEX LIFE IS SO SENSITIVE THAT
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO TELL
BUSINESS YOU CAN'T USE THIS
UNLESS IT'S REALLY NECESSARY TO
DELIVER A SERVICE I'M ASKING
FOR. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE AND ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT PARTS
THAT IS WHERE AM I WHERE'S MY
PRECISE LOCATION RIGHT NOW. AND
SO ONE OF THE PARTS OF THE SLIP
WOULD SAY LOOK IF YOU SAY DON'T
LIVE DON'T USE THAT'S A
PERSONAL YOU CAN'T TRACK THE
CLOSER THAN A CIRCLE WITH THE
RATES OF JUST OVER A THIRD OF A
MILE. WHICH DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
A LOT IN THEIR LIVES NO IT
ACTUALLY PUT INTO A IN THE ACRE.
WHAT IS I DEBT NEXT THIS IS HOW
IT FOR ADVERTISING THEY CAN
NóI OKLA RESIDENT THEY CAN
SHOW ME A CARD AB FOR OKLA. BUT
IT DOESN'T ALLOW THEM WHETHER I
IN THE SENATE. IN THE MOSQUE
I'M IN CANCER CENTER I MAY THE
GYM. I THINK IT'S SUPER. FOR
CAL. NEXT PLEASE. THE OTHER
THING IS AS AS- WAS ALLUDED TO
EARLIER WE CREATE. A NEW AGENCY
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS PRIVACY
FUNDED BY THE GENERAL FUND NEXT
PLEASE. I THINK ONE OF THE
REASON IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT
IS FUNDED BY THE GENERAL FUND
IS PEOPLE FORGET THE CALIFORNIA
HAD AN OFFICER PRIVACY
PROTECTION. AND IT WAS ZEROED
OUT BY GOVERNOR BROWN IN TWENTY
TWELVE TO BUDGET CONCERNS. AND
AS LONG AS THAT- CONSTRUCT
REMAINS WHICH IS THE CASE WITH
THE CURRENT FORSMAN YOU HAVE A
POTENTIAL WEAKENING CEMEX LIVE
PLEASE. PEOPLE SAID OH IT'S
ONLY TEN MILLION DOLLARS
ALISTAIR WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN
YOU'RE UP AGAINST TRILLION
DOLLAR CORPORATIONS. AND I SAY
FAIR ENOUGH BUT GUESS WHAT.
THIS IS MANY THIS SHOULD. ALLOW
FOR THE HIRING OF AS MANY
PRIVACY PRETTY PROFESSIONALS AS
THE FTC HAS FOR THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. PEOPLE COMPARE THIS
BUDGET TO THE FTC'S BUT THAT'S
NOT THE RIGHT COMPARISON THE
RIGHT COMPARISON IS TO HOW MUCH
THE FTC SPENT ON PRIVACY THEY
HAVE FORTY PRIVACY
PROFESSIONALS FOR THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY WE SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
THIS WILL BE A VERY ROBUST-
PRIVACY AGENCY AND BY THE WAY.
NOTHING PREVENTS LEGISLATURE
FOR DECIDING- THIS IS IMPORTANT
WE'RE GOING TO ADD MORE MONEY
TO IT BUT THIS IS A BASS LINE
AND WILL ENSURE CONTINUITY.
NEXT PLEASE. WE WILL HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO LOG THESE VERY
IMPORTANT PRIVACY PRINCIPLES
PURPOSE LIMITATION TELL ME WHY
YOU'RE COLLECTING MY
INFORMATION AND DON'T USE FOR
OTHER THINGS. STORAGE
LIMITATION. TELL ME HOW LONG
YOU'RE GONNA CLICK MY
INFORMATION. DON'T KEEP IT ANY
LONGER DATA MINIMIZATION. WHY
ARE YOU CLICK MY INFORMATION
OKAY ONLY COLLECT ENOUGH TO DO
THE THING YOU SAY YOU'RE GONNA
DO. NEXT PLEASE OTHER
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE NEW RIGHT
TO CORRECT YOUR INFORMATION
NEXT PLEASE. AS A RIGHT TO SEE
ALL OF YOUR INFORMATION FROM
THE BEGINNING OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO ON WORK SO NOT THE CCP IS
JUST THE LAST YEAR THIS WILL
NOW BE ALL OF YOUR INFORMATION.
NEXT PLEASE REALLY IMPORTANTLY
WE REMOVE THE CURRENT CONSTRUCT
WHICH IS A SORT OF A TWO
STRIKES ROUTE WHICH ACTUALLY IS
WHAT THE FTC HOUSE RIGHT YOU
NOTICE THE COMPANY YOU SAID AS
A VIOLATION. AND THEN IF THEY
HAVEN'T CURED IN THIRTY DAYS
THEN YOU CAN START THE FINING
BUT THAT'S NOT PERHAPS THE MOST
ROBUST CONSTRUCTS SO WHAT THIS
LAW WOULD DO IS SAY NO IF
YOU'RE FILING A LAWYER LIABLE
FOR THE VIOLATION. NEXT PLEASE.
WE TRIPLE THE PENALTIES FOR
MINOR TRIM FOR VIOLATIONS OF
MINORS PRIVACY. FIVE THREE
LITTLE KIDS I'VE BEEN DOING A
LOT OF A SCHOOL LEARNING AT
HOME LAST COUPLE MONTHS. AND
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S OUT OF
CONTROL YOU'RE BEING ASKED TO
UPLOAD THIS PROJECT TO THIS
WEBSITE AND- THERE HAVE TO BE
ON THIS WEBSITE AND YOU KNOW
POSSIBLY HAVE TIME TO GO
THROUGH ALL THE PRIVACY
POLICIES OF ALL THESE THINGS
THE AT THE KIDS PRIVACY IS
BEING. MONITORED THEIR THEIR
THEIR PERFORMANCES BEING
MODERATE. WE REALLY IF THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS HAVE HOWN ONE
THING IS THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
PROTECT KIDS PRIVACY. I AM
REALLY FOCUS ON THAT. NEXT
PLEASE ONE OF THE OTHER
ENHANCEMENTS WE ADD EMAIL AND
PASSWORD. TO THE LIST OF ITEMS
IS SUBJECT TO THE NEGLIGENT DID
REACH SECTION SO JUST REMIND
PEOPLE SECTION ONE FIFTY IS
THIS NOTION THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO COLLECT INFORMATION TO
KEEP IT SAFE. AND IF YOU DON'T
HAVE REASONABLE PRACTICES AND
PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO PROTECT
INFORMATION AND YOU'RE LIABLE
AND THERE'S A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION ON THAT IN THIS SECTION.
WELL SO MUCH DATA IDENTITY
THEFT STARTS WITH YOU KNOW
EMAIL HACKING AND YOUR PASSWORD
SO IF THE COMPANY. WASN'T SAFE
WITH YOUR EMAIL PASSWORD THAT'S
ADDED TO THE- TO THE LIST OF
THINGS WORKS THERE SUBJECT TO
THE NEXT A DATA BREACH SECTION.
NEXT PLEASE. HIGH RISK
BUSINESSES BUSINESSES THAT ARE
COLLECTING THAT REALLY
SENSITIVE INFORMATION THAT ARE
USE THAT THAT'S REFER MISSION.
THOSE BUSINESSES ARE REQUIRED
PERFORMANCE ANNUAL
CYBERSECURITY OUGHT. NEXT
PLEASE. THEY'LL BE THE
APPOINTMENT OF A CHIEF PRIVACY
AUDITOR TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
PRIVACY IN THE STATE. NEXT
PLEASE. THIS IS REALLY TOP OF
MIND NOW- THERE WILL BE THE
PROVISION TO ALLOW. ARE BEING
CREATED ABOUT YOU. AND SO RIGHT
NOW ARE YOU SEEN JOBS BASED ON
YOUR GENDER BASED ON YOUR RACE
HOW DO HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING AND THIS WILL
REQUIRE THAT THE COMPANIES THAT
ARE CREATING THESE PROFILES
ABOUT YOU. PROVIDES MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION OF THE LOGIC
INVOLVED IN THOSE IN THOSE
ALGORITHMS AND ALSO ALLOW YOU
TO STOP TRIPS TO OBJECT TO THE
AUTOMATED AUTOMATE AUTOMATIC
DECISION MAKING THIS BE MADE
BASED ON THESE PROFILES. NEXT
PLEASE. IN ADDITION- IT'LL
ALLOW. CONSUMERS TO HAVE MUCH
MORE CONTROL OVER WHAT'S CALLED
BEHAVIORAL ADVERTISING AND
BEHAVIORAL ADVERTISING MEMBERS
RELATIVELY NEW IT'S NOT THE
TECHNOLOGY THE BILL DOES FOR
GOOGLE FACEBOOK- WHICH WAS MORE
CONTEXTUAL ADVERTISING
CONTEXTUALIZE YOU SEE AN AD
BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE READING OR
LOOKING AT. WEST OPERATE
PRIVACY- DETRIMENTAL THE
BEHAVIORAL ADVERTISING IS WERE
THEY CREATED DOSSIER BASED ON
YOUR ACTIVITIES WHAT WEBSITES
YOU'VE VISITED BASED ON THE
FACT THEIR TRIANGULAR IN YOUR
PHONE IN YOUR DESKTOP COMPUTER
IN YOUR PARTNER'S COMPUTER AND
YOUR- YOUR WORK COMPUTER AND
THEY CREATE THIS MASSIVE DASI
ABOUT YOU AND THEN THEY CAN USE
THAT TO- ADVERTISE TO WHICH IS
RIGHT INFLUENCE YOU. SO THIS
GIVES YOU MUCH MORE CONTROL
OVER STOPPING THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S MUCH MORE PRIVACY
INVASIVE THEN THE CONTEXTUAL
ADVERTISING. NEXT PLEASE. IN
ESSENCE YOU KNOW WHAT. A WE'VE
HAD TWO YEARS TO LOOK AT GPR AT
THE EUROPEAN LAW TWO YEARS LOOK
AT CPA. I THINK WE'VE IMPROVE
BOTH A DRAMATICALLY AND I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT IF THIS
PASSES IN NOVEMBER IT'LL BE
BEST IN CLASS IN THE IN THE
WORLD WILL BE THEMOST
EFFECTIVE PRICE LEGISLATION
WORLD. NEXT PLEASE. SO NOW
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
WORK ABILITY ENHANCEMENTS AGAIN
THOSE ARE AREAS WHERE WE THINK
WE CAN IMPROVE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LAW AND
NOT HER PRIVACY. NEXT PLEASE.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE ARE
GOING BACK TO THE DEFINITION WE
HAD IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN- IN THE
ORIGINAL ISSUED OF- FOR
BUSINESS. AND THAT IS GOING UP
FROM FIFTY THOUSAND RECORDS
YEAR TO BUSINESSES THAT
MONETIZE COLLECT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND RECORDS A YEAR. AND
WERE. RIGHT NOW IT'S THERE'S A
THE- TERM RECEIVES OR SHARES
FOR COMMERCIAL PURPOSE. TAKING
THAT OUT AND ASSIST YOU TO BE
CLEAN BUYER CELL BECAUSE WHAT.
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM THE PROBLEM IS
COMPANIES THAT BUY AND SELL
YOUR INFORMATION- AND SO WHAT
THIS WILL DO IS THE PROBLEM NOT
THE MOM AND POPS THE SMALL
LITTLE. CONTRACTOR SO WE'RE
GOING AFTER THE BUSINESSES AND
WE'RE TRYING TO- FURTHER
REFINED THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE WHERE THE PROBLEM IS. BY
THE WAY YOUR SMALL LITTLE BIT
BROKER YOU ARE COVERED. NEXT
PLEASE. SERVICE WHAT IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF A OF A WIN WIN SO-
THINK OF A SERVICE PROVIDER
THINK OF IT LIKE IT'S A BANK
WITH A SAFETY DEPOSIT BOX YOU
KNOW YOU GO TO CITY DEPOSIT BOX
YOU DON'T WANT THE BANK TO BE
ABLE TO SEE WHAT YOU HAVE WELL
THE CLOUD PROVIDERS ARE MUCH
LIKE THAT YOUR BUSINESS YOU
HOST YOUR YOUR SERVICES ON THE
CLOUD- THE COVER LETTER DOESN'T
ACTUALLY WANT TO SEE YOUR
INTERNAL BUSINESS DOCUMENTS
EVERYTHING OR YOU WANT THE CLUB
BETTER TO SEE THEM. RIGHT NOW
IN THE LAW THE REGULATION HAVE
ADDRESS THIS BUT RIGHT NOW IN
THE LAW. YOU CAN GO TO A CLUB
PROVIDERS SAY WHAT YOU KNOW
ABOUT ME UP TO IS A W. S. HERE.
AND THEY WOULD SOMEHOW HAVE TO
REACH INTO ALL THE BUSINESSES
THEY HOST TO FIND OUT. YOU KNOW
IF YOUR CUSTOMER AND WHAT THEY
KNOW ABOUT YOU THAT'S BAD FOR.
THE BUSINESS THAT'S TERRIBLE
FOR YOU THE CONSUMER BECAUSE
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE THAT
LEVEL. OF KNOWLEDGE THAT THAT
THAT THAT BUSINESSES FOR THE
BIG BROTHER. SO THIS IS A WIN
WIN- AND WE WOULD- SAY SEEM TO
BE THE SERVICE BETTER HAS TO.
ASSIST THE BUSINESS YOU HAVE
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH. NEXT
PLEASE. NOW THIS ONE I WANT TO
SPEND A LITTLE TIME ON- BECAUSE
THIS IS- THERE'S A LOT OF
CONFUSION OUT THERE ABOUT THIS-
THIS PARTICULAR ENHANCEMENT. SO
RIGHT NOW. UNDERSEA CPA IF YOU
OPT OUT OF THE SALE OF YOUR IN.
A BUSINESS CAN TAKE ACTION THEY
CAN CHARGE YOU SOMETHING IT CAN
DIMINISH YOUR SERVICE- IT HAS
TO TELL YOU THE CONSEQUENCE HAS
TO BE REASONABLE IT CAN'T BE ON
JUST USER IS CAN'T BE COURSE OF
THE CAN'T SORT OF FORCE YOU
INTO SELLING INFORMATION BUT
THEY CAN. HAVE A CONSEQUENCE
NOW THIS IS BEEN A REALLY
CONTENTIOUS PARTY CPA A LOT OF
ADVOCATES HERE BECAUSE THEY SAY
THIS IS PAY FOR PRIVACY. AND AS
WE WERE GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS LAST FALL WE WERE
TRYING TO REACH OUT TO FIND OUT
WHAT WOULD BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
REPAIRS WE COULD IMPROVE AND
ONE IDEA THAT CAME UP WAS LOOK
HAVE ANOTHER PATH. BECAUSE
BUSINESSES DON'T LIKE HAVING TO
PUT A DO NOT SELL BUTTON HAVE
ANOTHER PATH FOR BUSINESS THE
DON'T WANT TO DO NOT SELL
BUTTON. WHERE IF YOU SHOW UP OR
WHEN YOU SHOW UP WITH YOUR DO
NOT SELL SIGNAL FROM YOUR
BROWSER YOUR PHONE. THE
BUSINESS CAN'T TAKE ANY ACTION
CAN'T CHARGE YOU MORE CAN'T
RETALIATE CAN'T DIMINISH YOUR
SERVICE CAN'T HAVE A POP UP
SAYING YOU KNOW THE WORLD'S
GOING TO AND IF YOU DON'T LET
US AT SELL YOUR DATA. THE
IMPORTANT PART WHERE THE IF YOU
CAN IS. THE BUSINESS HAS TO
CHOOSE ONE OR THE OTHER DOOR IN
BOTH CASES THE BUSINESS MUST.
RESPECT THE DO NOT SELL SIGNAL
I WANT TO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT AGAIN IF PEOPLE. WERE
FALLING ALONG BABIES OUT THERE
WHO THAT IS A PRIVACY EXPERT IF
YOU LOOK AT SEVENTEEN NINETY
EIGHT ONE THIRTY FIVE BE. ANY
BE SAYS THE BUSINESS. IN THE
SECOND PATH HAS TO RESPECT YOUR
SIGNAL- THE DO NOT SELL SIGNAL
AND HE SAYS. IT ALSO HAS TO
RESPECT THE SIGNAL IF YOU HIRE
SERVICE TO DO IT. ONE OF THE
THINGS I'M CONVINCED WE'VE DONE
IS CREATE A PRIVACY INDUSTRY. A
LOT OF PEOPLE CHOOSE TO DO THIS
HIMSELF A LOT OF PEOPLE ALSO
WANT INSTALL AN APP OR HAVE A
GLOBAL SITTING ON THEIR PHONE.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR. THERE IS
NO GET OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD
HERE WE ARE. THAT WE ARE
KEEPING THE CPA CONSTRUCT IN
THIS AND WE'RE OFFERING ANOTHER.
PATH WHERE THE BUSINESS DOES
GET TO NOT HAVE TO DO NOT SELL.
BUTTON BUT IN RETURN CAN'T
CHARGE MORE. CAN'T HAVE ANY
CONSEQUENCE TO THE CUP. THE
CONSUMER WHO SHOWS UP WITH THE
DO NOT SELL SIGNAL I THINK THIS
IS A TREMENDOUS ENHANCEMENT
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. IS BROWSER EXTENSIONS
AND GLOBAL PHONE SETTINGS ARE
GONNA BECOME UBIQUITOUS PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO. ENABLE THEM AND
THE BUSINESSESARE GOING TO NOT
WANT TO HAVE TO DO NOT SELL
BUTTON BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO
INDICATE THEY ARE SELLING.
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO GO
THIS ROUTE AND CONSUMERS WILL
VOTE WITH THEIR FEET. AND THIS
WILL BECOME A TREMENDOUSLY
PRIVACY PROTECTIVE. THING FOR
CONSUMERS NEXT SLIDE PLEASE I
AM NEXT TO YOU CAN DO YEAH I
JUST THINK IT'S GONNA BE
COMPRESSOR FROM THE GO THIS
ROUTE FROM COMPETITORS ARE NOT
GOING TO WANT TO HAVE. THE DO
NOT SELL BUTTON. AND AGAIN I
THINK THIS IS GONNA BE BEST IN
CLASS IF YOU GO TO THE EUROPEAN
WEBSITE GET THE- GET THE COOKIE
WALLS ALL THE TIME- I THINK
THE- NOTION THAT YOU CAN. SAY
TO A BUSINESS AHEAD OF TIME
DON'T SO MY DATA. THE SUM OF
INFORMATION SHOW UP ON THE
BUSINESS AND HOW TO BE SEAMLESS
AND IT'S NOT SELLING
INFORMATION GETS GOING TO BE.
TREMENDOUSLY BENEFITS FOR
CONSUMERS. NEXT PLEASE. ANOTHER
AREA THAT'S GETS THAT'S GOT
SOME ATTENTION IN THIS REDRAFT
HAS BEEN AND DOES A NEW
DEFINITION. OF PUBLICLY.
AVAILABLE I JUST TOOK REMIND
FOLKS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. IN
THE- NEXT SLIDE PLEASE THAT IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN INITIATIVE.
WE SAID THAT PERSONAL
INFORMATION DOESN'T INCLUDE
INFORMATION IS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE AND IS A YOU CAN
THINK ABOUT THIS THE FIRST
MEMBER. POINT YOU IT'S PRETTY
OBVIOUS IF I'M ON THE STREET
CORNER HANDING OUT FLYERS ABOUT
MEDICATION TO MEXICO IT'S
UNLIKELY THAT I CAN BEEN CLAIM
THAT THAT'S PERSONAL
INFORMATION. SO AS PART OF OUR
PROCESS LAST FALL WE WENT
AROUND AND TALKED TO. AS I SAID
TONS OF EXPERTS. SO I DID TALK
TO ONE OR TWO WE TALKED UP FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW PROFESSORS.
AT ALL FOR GAVE US THE SAME
ADVICE. THAT THE CURRENT
DEFINITION OF PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE IN THE CPA IS TO
RESTRICT AND WON'T WORK. AND
THAT WE NEEDED TO AMEND. SO
AGAIN NOT A YOU KNOW MIGHT MY
PROCESS ALL LAST YEAR WAS TO GO
TALK THE BEST EXPERTS I COULD.
AND GET THE BEST ADVICE INTO
AND THINK THIS. SO NOW SLIDE
PLEASE NOW SEE VERY. A
EXCEPTION. FOR WIDELY
DISTRIBUTED MEDIA. OR FOR BY
INTENTIONAL- AT MY INTENTIONAL
ACTION SO IF I INTEND TO WRITE
A BLOG ABOUT MY TRIP TO MEXICO.
AND I DISTRIBUTE THAT ACTUALLY
I CAN'T BE PRIVATE ANYMORE.
CRITICIZED THE SAYING YOU'VE
MADE A WEAKER I HAVE ZERO
INTEREST IN MAKING THIS LAW
WEAKER ZERO OF ALL THE PEOPLE
OUT THERE I'VE GOT TO LEAST
INTEREST MAKE A SLOW WEEK. I DO
HOWEVER HAVE AN INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE THAT IT SURVIVED
THE TEST OF TIME. AND WHEN I
FOR CONSTITUTIONAL. FETTERS
ONLY TO DO SOMETHING. I THINK
I'M GONNA I'M GONNA LISTEN TO
THEM. WE MADE THIS IS NARROW IS
WE COULD. THE BEAUTY IS IF
THERE'S SOME CASE LAW IN THE
FUTURE THE CHANGES. AND TURNS
OUT IT CAN BE NARROWER FOR
GUESS WHAT THE LEGISLATURE TO
PASS A LAW NARROWING THIS
EXEMPTION. SO AGAIN I THINK
THIS IS A IS A WORK BUILDING
HAS BEEN THAT THAT HELPS THE
LOS SURVIVE FOR LONG TERM NEXT
PLEASE. AND HAVING JUST TALKED
ABOUT FLEXIBILITY IN THE
LEGISLATURE CHANGING LET'S TALK
ABOUT. HOW THE LEGISLATURE'S
ROLE. WOULD CHANGE WITH RESPECT
TO THIS INITIATIVE GOING FOR.
NOW MANY INITIATIVE SHOW UP AND
IF THEY PASSED THEY HAVE
PROVISIONS SAYING YOU NEED TWO
THIRDS OF BOTH HOUSES OR THREE
QUARTERS OF A VOTE BOTH HOUSES
THEY REALLY DON'T WANT TO BE
CHANGED BECAUSE SEPARATE
THEMSELVES FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
AND I'M ON RECORD SAYING LOOK I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT
LEGISLATURE'S IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IS THE PLACE TO MAKE
THE LAWS. SO THIS INITIATIVE
SIMPLY SAYS. GUESS WHAT
MAJORITY VOTE TO CHANGE THE LAW
IN THE FUTURE. AND NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE THERE'S ONE STIPULATION
AND ALL ACTUALLY DO NEXT LIES
WELL TO- ALL. THE ONLY THING.
THAT WE SAY IS THAT YOU CAN'T
HAVE AN AMENDMENT THAT HURTS
CONSUMER PRIVACY ANY OTHER
MEMBER YOU WANT GREAT. BUT NOT
ONE THAT HURTS CONSUMER PRIVACY
NOW SOME PEOPLE CRITICIZED ME
FOR THIS. MY ANSWER THAT IS
FIND ME THE LEGISLATOR IN THIS
BUILDING WHO PUT UP THEIR HANDS
IS NO WE NEED THE FLEXIBILITY
TO HER CONSUMER PRIVACY GOING
FORWARD THERE ISN'T ONE. I MEAN
THE BUSINESS ADVOCATE WHO'LL
SAY THAT NO ONE'S GONNA SAY AT
THIS IS MOTHERHOOD AND APPLE
PIE WE'RE MERELY SAYING WE'RE
INTRODUCING. POLICY FLOOR IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH PROTECT.
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMER. PRIVACY
GOING FORWARD. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE I'M NOT GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE FISCAL ANALYSIS
BECAUSE- I NEED TO TALK ABOUT
THAT NEXT PLEASE. DO I SPEND A
LITTLE TIME ON THE- REGULATORY
IMPACT ASSESSMENT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S GONNA COME UP
LATER ON TODAY. THIS IS THE
FAMOUS ASSESSMENT THAT SAID
THAT THE COST OF CCPA WHICH IS
NOT. THIS INITIATIVE I WANNA
TALK WITH THE CITY ANYWAY IT'S
GOING TO BE FIFTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE STATE SO NEXT-
THING I JUST WANT TO SAY I'VE
BEEN THROUGH A LOT OF STUDIES
I'M A BUSINESS PERSON. I THERE
ARE IN MY MIND SOME SERIOUS
METAL OF METHODOLOGICAL FLAWS
IN THIS STUDY. WHEN THEY EXCEPT
TO BE SHARED SUPPOSED TO SHARE
FOR COMMERCIAL PURPOSES. NEXT
PLEASE LATE THAT THE FIGURE
FIFTY FIVE BILLION SECTION JUST
OUT OF THIS NO TABLE IS NO. SET
OF CALCULATIONS AND HOW THEY
GOT THERE. NEXT PLEASE. THEY
THEY THEY RELIED ON TO STUDIES
THAT WERE DIED. PP ONCE JUST
ONE THE PEOPLE COULD CHOOSE TO
TAKE THERE WAS NEXT LIKELY
THERE WAS NO CALIFORNIA ONLY
SURVEY DATA. SO ONE OF THE
STUDIES WAS HAD SIXTY COMPANIES
OF FIVE HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT'S- THE COMPANY. THE
OTHER ONE AT FIFTY ONE
COMPANIES OF ONE TO TWO FIFTY.
THIS IS NATIONALLY. AND FROM
THAT NEXT. SLIDE PLEASE THEY
CONCLUDED THAT EVERY CAL.
BUSINESS OR FIVE. AS SUMMER
BETWEEN TWENTY TWO AND 62% OF
THE ONES. ONE FOUR PLEASE WOULD
BE COVERED BY THE CPA. WELL WE
ALL KNOW THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
BUSINESSES ARE TINY LITTLE
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. TO
THIS THE HANDYMAN THAT THAT
THEY WERE ASSUMING THAT ALL THE
HANDYMAN AND ALL THAT. ALL THE
THREE LITTLE ONES EVERYTHING
GONNA BE COVERED. HI THIS LAW
AND IT'S CLEARLY NOT THE INTENT
AND SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
BECAUSE I THINK PEOPLE BRING IT
UP. LATER YOU'RE HERE IN YOUR
TRAVELS. I WANT TO PROTECT.
STRONGLY AGAINST OCEAN THAT THE
FIFTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
FIGURES I THINK ROBUST. NEXT
PLEASE. SO WHAT NEXT STEPS WE
SUBMITTED- NINE AND THREE ONE
THOUSAND SIGNATURES EARLY IN
MAY- FUN FACT LAST TIME AROUND
IT WAS MORE PEOPLE THAN LIVED
IN TWO STATES NOW IT'S- MORE
PEOPLE MORECALIFORNIA
REGISTERED VOTERS AND LIVE IN.
FIVE STATES WERE DC- NEXT TO
YOU CAN DO- BACK UP ON THANKS
TO WE NEED SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND TO QUALIFY- AS OF
MONDAY WE WERE AT FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND IT'S A
LITTLE- I WOULD LIKE TO DO MORE
UPDATED FIGURE BUT WE HAVEN'T
BEEN UPDATED SINCE MONDAY EVEN
THOUGH THE- OTHER- INITIATIVES
HAVE BEEN UP THERE TWICE SINCE
MONDAY SO WE'RE- WE'RE A LITTLE
BIT. WONDERING WHAT THEY'RE-
COMFORT THAT WE WILL QUALIFY-
BY THE TWENTY FIFTH NEXT PLEASE.
THIRTY ONE A CLOSE IN TALKING
ABOUT US CONSUMER- REGULATION
HISTORY. I THINK IT'S LIKELY TO
PRESS THE FOR ME BECAUSE I
THINK. WE SEE THIS MOVIE OR IT
HAPPENS AGAIN AND AGAIN AND WE
DON'T LEARN FROM. AND I THINK
PRIVACY IS A MOVEMENT WHOSE
TIME HAS COME. AND SO IF YOU TO
THE NEXT SLIDE HERE LET'S TAKE
A LOOK AT SOME PROMINENT
EXAMPLES SO YEARS AUTO SAFETY.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN THE WHOLE
CITY MOVEMENT FOR STARTED THE
COMPANY A QUIRK OF HIS FOUGHT
IT TOOTHAND NAIL. AND THEY
WERE NOT EXCITED ABOUT THE
NOTION OF HAVING PUTTING
AIRBAGS WERE HAVING TO PUT A
LOT OF SAFETY FEATURES. AND NOW
FAST FORWARD FIFTY SIX YEARS
THINK ABOUT TRYING TO THE CAR
WITHOUT EBS BREAKS ARE ABOUT
WITHOUT. YOU KNOW AIR BAG
WITHOUT SAFETY COUPLES ON YOU
CONSUMER WOULD LOOK YOU SIDE
WITH JUST LIKE NO WAY MY MIND
THAT CAR. THE NEXT PLEASE-
SMOKING YOU KNOW DOES ANYBODY
THINK THAT THEY REALLY MISS
WALKING TO A SMOKE FILLED BAR-
THIS THE TOBACCO COMPANIES
FUNDED TONS A BOGUS STUDIES BUT
THE REALITY IS THE REGULATIONS
IMPROVED LIFE WE DON'T HAVE
BEEN CIGARETTE VENDING MACHINES
IN HIGH SCHOOLS ANYMOREFOR A
REASON. NEXT PLEASE- THIS ONE
YOU KNOW AUTO EMISSIONS THIS IS
WHERE CALIFORNIA REALLY TOOK
THE LEAD IN- IT TREMENDOUS WAVE
NATIONALLY- AND AS GOOD AS KEPT
LEAD NATIONALLY WE WERE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW SEE ACROSS LOS ANGELES
ON A CLEAR DAY OR THERE WAS NO
CLEAR DAYS BEFORE AND NOW YOU
CAN. THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE
FOR THE REGULATIONS AND AGAIN
THIS WAS RESISTED PRETTY-
FIRMLY AT THE TIME. NEXT PLEASE.
I THINK IN CLOSING THE FOR ME
ONE OF THE REASONS THIS IS SUCH
pTHIS INFORMATION. IS USED
DIFFERENTLY BY DIFFERENT
SOCIETIES AND IF WITH THE AYE
AYE I SORT OF STABLE FORGET THE
IRON CURTAIN IS NOW THE DATA
CURTAIN AND IF YOU LOOK AT SAY
FOR EXAMPLE CHINA. THIS
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE IT'S
UBIQUITOUS AND IT'S USE FOR
SOCIAL CONTROL IT IS USED TO
STIFLE DISSENT IT IS USED TO.
FOR FLOOD CONTROL. AND NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE BUT THE
INTERESTING THING THOUGH IS WE
HAVE THAT INFORMATION HERE IT'S
ALL AVAILABLE HERE. AND THIS IS
FROM AN ARTICLE THE NEW YORK
TIMES DID- DID DID RECENTLY
WHICH- SHOWED HOW EASY IT IS.
FOR INDIVIDUALS. WHO IN IN WHAT
ELECT TECHIES WORKED AT A
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT IN THE
WRITING CASE WORKERS WORSHIP
THAT A PARTICULAR CHURCH. TO BE
TRACKED BACK TO THEIR HOMES TO
IT TO BE IDENTIFIED. THAT
ARTICLE TALKED ABOUT THE OPERA
SINGER. WHO SANG AT GEORGE HW
BUSH'S SERVICE NATIONAL
CATHEDRAL BEING TRACKED BACK TO
HOME AND THEN BE IDENTIFIED
FROM HER PHONE. AND HOW ALARMED
AND SHE WAS WHEN SHE WAS
CONTACTED. SO I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT THIS ENDEAVOR THAT YOU ARE
ENGAGED IN THIS COMMITTEE. THAT
SENATOR DODD YOU ENGAGE IN TWO
YEARS AGO IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IT IS- IS
FOUNDATIONAL TO THE KIND OF
SOCIETY WE ARE GOING TO. CREATE
AND LEAVE FOR OUR CHILDREN. AND
I'M PROUD TO BE PART OF THAT
PART OF THIS JOURNEY I'LL GET I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. I'M HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER MACAQUE GUARD
BEFORE WE GO TO QUESTIONS I
WANT TO WELCOME. MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF A FEW WEEKS
TO THE HEARING. THE DESIGN
WHICH LIKE TO MAKE IN YOUR
OPENING REMARKS. I THINK THIS
THING FOR ME APPRECIATED I JUST
I'LL HAVE QUESTIONS FOLLOW AND
SORRY I MISSED PART OF YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT- WE'LL DIVE IN
AND STUFF. VERY GOOD. MAYBE I
SHOULD START WITH THE FIRST
QUESTION FIRST QUESTION GOES TO
MISLEAD OF FROM THE L. L. L.'S
OFFICE. MISLI UP THE PROPOSED
INITIATIVE IS- SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE PRESCRIPTIVE- WITH RESPECT
TO THE USE OF MONIES. ALLOCATED
TO THE CONSUMER PRIVACY FUN.
BUT THEN THE CCPA. A PROVIDING
A MUCH LESS FLEXIBILITY FOR
LET'S SAY DISCRETIONARY. USE OF
THE FUNDS IN AN ACCESS OF WHAT
IS NECESSARY. TO ENFORCE THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. NOW IN
LIGHT OF THE NEW DEMANDS SO THE
STATE NOW FACES- DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN AND THE EVER CHANGING
LANDSCAPE OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY. UP DO YOU TEXAS
HERE IS THE QUESTION DO YOU
FORESEE ANY ISSUES. EITHER FOR
THE ENFORCEMENT OF THE CONSUMER
PRIVACY LAWS OR FOR ANY OTHER
STATE FUNCTIONS WHICH UP WITH
THESE FUNDS EARMARKED FOR
PARTICULAR PURPOSE IN AND IF
THAT'S CONFUSING OKAY CAN
REPEAT THAT QUESTION. THE
QUESTION IS DO YOU DO YOU
FORESEE ANY ISSUES OF EITHER
FOR THE ENFORCEMENT OF CONSUMER
PRIVACY LAWS OR FOR OTHER STATE
FUNCTIONS WITH THESE FUNDS
EARMARKED FOR PARTICULAR
PURPOSES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THAT- I I'M GONNA DO MY
BEST TO ANSWER THAT FOR YOU CAN
TELL ME WHETHER OR NOT- I DO
SO- FIRST IN TERMS OF THINKING
ABOUT THE MONIES THAT ARE GOING
INTO THE CONSUMER PRIVACY FINE-
BUT YOU HAVE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE ABLE TO GO
INTO A FAX RELATED TO THAT THE
CPPA. ALWAYS STARTING SHORTLY-
ENFORCEMENT RELATED TO THESE
NEW REQUIREMENTS KICK AND A
LITTLE BIT LATER- AND SO IF THE
TIMING IS A LITTLE BIT OF
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT
BECAUSE WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS THE LEGISLATURE
IS WEIGHING CONCERNS RELATED TO
THE ECONOMY AS WELL AS
ADDRESSING COPE IN NINETEEN-
AND SO I'M THINKING ABOUT KIND
OF THAT PENALTY REVENUE THERE'S
ALREADY A LITTLE GOING TO BE A
LITTLE BIT OF A LACK- I THINK
THE SECOND ISSUE IS THE FIRST
USE OF THE MONEY AS FOR STATE
COURT AND DOJ COSTS. AND SO I
THINK THAT UNDER EXISTING LAW
AS WELL AS THIS YOU PROPOSAL
THE PRIMARY FOCUS IS KIND OF ON
ENFORCEMENT THERE MAYBE
INTERPRETATIONS FOR HOW MUCH
ENFORCEMENT S NEEDED AND SO IN
THE IN THE- LAND IS UNDER THE
LEGISLATURE'S PURVIEW. I IF
THEY THINK MORE MONEY IS
NECESSARY OR NEED IT.
LEGISLATURE CERTAINLY CAN
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL MONEY BUT IT
DOES BECOME A TRADE OFF
DISCUSSION FOR THE LEGISLATURE
GIVEN OTHER GENERAL FUND
PRIORITY AND SO THAT CAN
INCLUDE THINGS COMPLETELY
OUTSIDE EDUCATION- EXCEPT OUR
HEALTH CARE IT ON THOSE AREAS.
SIMILARLY YOU KNOW IF. THE
LEGISLATURE THINGS THAT MORE
MONEY SHOULD BE DEDICATED TO
THE END OF THIS AREA SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THERE IS A CONCERNED
WITH- EDUCATING INDIVIDUALS
LIKE CENTER AT HELPING OUT
BUSINESSES THAT'S ANOTHER
PRIORITY THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN PUT INTO PLACE BUT I THINK
THE KEY THING THAT I WANT TO
KIND OF HIGHLIGHT IS. RELATED
TO THE NINETY ONE PERCENT-
INVESTMENT OF DOLLARS AS WELL
AS THAN THAT BUT 9% GOING TO
FIND- EDUCATION ETCETERA THAT
IS GOING TO KIND OF TAKE A
FACT. A LITTLE BIT LATER IN
TERMS OF LIKE WE NEED TO SEE
THE REVENUE AND THEN IT WOULD
ONLY NEED TO GET OUT SO THAT'S
NOT NECESSARILY SOMETHING THAT
YOU WOULD BE DEALING WITH
IMMEDIATELY I DON'T KNOW IF
HOPE. THAT'S HELPFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I HAVE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS FOR MR MCTAGGART BUT
DAHLE IMAGES ALTERNATE MAYBE
I'LL START OFF WITH THE FIRST
QUESTION AND AN OPEN- FOR MY
COLLEAGUES OF FOR THE
QUESTIONS- I THINK THE FIRST
QUESTION DEALS WITH THE- AND
EVERY THAT YOU STARTED TO TOUCH
ON AND I WANT TO ELABORATE ON
THAT QUESTION A LITTLE BIT AND
IF YOU COULD. OF YOU KNOW DO A
LITTLE DEEPER DIVE OFF OF FOR
THE FOR THE ANSWER SO THE
QUESTION IS WHY IS NOW THE TIME
TO DISPEL INITIATIVE WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU TRY TO ARGUE
ANSWER. ON WHICH OVERWRITES THE
CCPA WHEN WE HAVE JUST BEGUN
IMPLEMENTING CC YEAH I WOULD BE
BETTER TO BUILD UPON THE CCPA.
IN BUSINESS. WHAT TO. AXIS
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER SIEGE SO IT
I KNOW IT'S A LOT QUESTION. SO
WHY IS NOW THE TIME TO RUN
ABOUT IT. WE IS ESSENTIALLY
OVER RIGHTS TO SOME X. THE CCPA
WHEN WE HOW JUST BEGUN
IMPLEMENTING THE CCPA. SECOND
PART OF THE QUESTION. WOULDN'T
IT BE BETTER TO BUILD UPON THE
CCPA. AFTER CONSUMER AFTER
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES HAVE
MORE TIME TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THIS HE'S. WELL
AGAIN AS I AS I AS I AS I TRIED
TO- ELABORATE EARLIER- MY
PROFOUND CONVICTION IS THIS IS
NOT OVER WRITING CCP THIS IS
BUILDING ON THE CPA SO THIS IS
THIS IS ENHANCING CCPA. A BEAR
IN MIND THERE'S A LONG RUNWAY
HERE THAT THIS- ENFORCEMENT FOR
THIS ACT IF IT PASSES WOULD
START IN THE MIDDLE OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE JULY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SO LET ME LOTS OF TIME
FOR THE CPA TO BE IN EFFECT.
AND I'D- AGAIN ALSO BUILDING ON
THE FACT REMINDING- THE FACT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE STILL WILL
HAVE TOTAL FLEXIBILITY. TO DEAL
WITH. ANY CHANGES THAT WANTS TO
MAKE. IN IN THE COMING YEARS-
IT'S NOTHING ABOUT THIS STOPS
LEGISLATURE FROM MAKING ANY
CHANGES. IT JUST MERELY AGAIN
CONCEPT FLOOR THRESHOLD IN SO I
THINK THAT IT THIS IS A IS. A
CREATIVE. THIS THIS THIS BUILT
ON AND I THINK- AT FOR THE TO
THE REASONS I SAID EARLIER.
COULD IN THE NATIONAL ONE-
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT- IT PUT
FLOOR FOR CALIFORNIA THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT. RIGHT
NOW. THANK MUCH BEFORE WE GO.
QUESTION I WANT TO WELCOME A-
US SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR
JOINING US SENATORS FOR
OBVIOUSLY IS THE SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER- AND- SO I WANT
TO WELCOME YOU AND AT THIS TIME
LIKE TO SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY
OPENING REMARKS ARE. LIKELY
REMARKS. TO THE AUDIENCE YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN
APOLOGIZE. WORK IN ANOTHER.
CRITICAL ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIA
BUT YEAH I DO AND I APPRECIATE
THAT I. WASN'T ABLE TO LISTEN
TO THE REMARK SO FAR IN THIS
HEARING AND I APOLOGIZE FOR MY
DELAY AND I. OR START UP BY
THANKING YOU IN THE EFFORTS
THAT WE ENGAGE IN. GO BOTH A
LOT OF SLEEPLESS NIGHTS AROUND
THE CLOCK WORK. TO DO THE
EXTRAORDINARY- EFFORT THAT WE
WROTE TO AND WAS A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WAS IT THAT WE CAN'T
REMEMBER THE CALL COME TOGETHER
WITH WITH THE INITIAL PRIVACY
ACT THAT QUITE FRANKLY. BEING
CANDID YOU KNOW WE'LL WE'LL WE
WERE TRYING TO GET- MYSTERY TAG
WHICH MEASURE OFF THE BALLOT I
HAD WORKED FOR MANY YEARS
PREVIOUSLY ON ON REFORMING THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS STARTING IN
TWO THOUSAND SPEAKERS.
COMMISSION INITIATIVE REFORM TO
TRY TO CREATE SOME MORE
DIALOGUE BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT AND PROPONENTS AND
THIS WAS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT AND
WE SPENT HUNDREDS OF HUNDREDS
OF HOURS. WITH MR MCTAGGART AND
OTHERS- IN EFFORT TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT WE THOUGHT.
WOULD WORK REASONABLY WELL. BUT
THIS AREA PRIVACY IS INFORMED
IN A DIFFERENT WAY BY ISSUES
THAT WE DON'T NORMALLY SEE IN
THE LEGISLATURE FIRST HIT IS
SUCH A FAST MOVING- TECHNOLOGY
INFORMED. AREA OF THE LAW THAT
SOME OF THESE THINGS WOULD EVEN
KNOW THAT HAPPENED WHO KNEW
ABOUT COUNT STEPS ARE HEART
BEATS OUR GEO LOCATION OR ALL
THOSE THINGS. SO THAT BECOMES
QUITE CHALLENGING SECONDLY.
WHERE THERE MIGHT OFTEN BE A
FIGHT BETWEEN LABOR AND
BUSINESS OR CERTAIN MEDICAL
INTERESTS OR DOCTORS OR LAWYERS
THIS WAS QUITE CHALLENGING
BECAUSE THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
DIFFERENT COMPANIES HAVE USED
DIFFERENT ECONOMIC MODELS.
TRYING DEVELOP THEIR BUSINESS.
WE FOUND IN THESE DISCUSSIONS
WHERE WE'RE COMPANY A SOUGHT IT
WAS A GOOD IDEA COMPANY BE LONG
COMES ALONG AND THEY WANT TO
KILL IT BECAUSE IT WAS
INCONSISTENT WITH THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL. IT WAS QUITE A
CHALLENGE AND SO THE EFFECT OF
WAS AND IS YOU KNOW THIS MISTER-CHAIRMAN I YOU MAY HAVE ALREADY
SAID THIS SO I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT BUT IN OUR EFFORT UNDER
YOUR MEASURE. THE IDEA WAS THAT
WE WOULD ARE. BY THE BILL. GET
MISTER MIKE TAGGERT MAY A THE
BALLOT AND WE DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR A YEAR. AND
THE REASON WE DID IMPLICATION
FOR YEARS THAT WE DIDN'T FEEL.
IN THE HONOR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE HAD THE
TIME WE HAD OUR BRIEF HEARINGS
THAT YOU WERE PRESENT THAT. TO
REALLY ENGAGE IN KIND OF SCREW.
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY WELL NO
NO ONE BELIEVE WE CAN GET OFF
THE BALLOT DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
POSSIBLE. PEOPLE KIND OF FUN
THEIR NOSE AT US IN IN KIND OF
QUITE FRANKLY. AND NO ONE
THOUGHT IT WAS POSSIBLE. SO IF
YOU REMEMBER WE GAVE THEM A
DOOR A AMADOR VIA. OPTIONS AND
THEY SELECTED THE ONE THE
MEASURE THAT WAS THE CPA. BUT
THE BY MY HOPE WAS THAT WE
WOULD ENGAGE IN A VERY ROBUST
DEBATE. IN THE FOLLOWING YEAR
TO BE ABLE TO SCRUB THE
LEGISLATION WE KNEW GOING IN
THAT THERE WERE MISTAKES TAT
WE MADE. AND EFFECTS AT. FACT
OF THE MATTER WAS NOT MUCH
HAPPENED WHY IS A RELEVANT BUT
IT IT'S JUST NOT MUCH HAPPENED.
AND THE QUESTION THEN BECAME
YOU KNOW I FELT QUITE FRANKLY
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE WITH APPRECIATE THIS THE
OF TORTILLA THAT WAS GIVEN TO
THEM SHE CPA. AND CREATED SOME
CHALLENGES JUST JUST PUT IT
THERE AND SO WE WERE LOOKING AT
OPTIONS AND WE WERE TRYING TO
EXPLORE AN OPTION TO TRADE
AGENCY. THAT COULD BASICALLY DO
THIS LIKE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LIKE THE YOU KNOW
THE F. T. I MEAN THE ELECTIONS
YEAH TRADE COMMISSION ALWAYS OF
THE COMMISSION TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE CAN WITH THE
ELEGANT WAY. THAT WILL WAITED
FAVOR OF BUSINESSES THAT WITH
INDUSTRY HEAVY BUT JUST TO AWAY.
IT WAS A CONCERT OF ALL OF THAT.
ON WHAT WAS CLEAR WAS WE JUST
COULDN'T GET ANYWHERE. WAS
FURTHER CLEAR WAS THAT- IN A
LARGER DYNAMIC THAT THIS ISSUE
OF PRIVACY WAS BECOMING BIGGER
AND BIGGER. BIGGER PRIVACY
RIGHTS GROUP. YOU KNOW PERSONAL
DATA AS IT IS A SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION THAT
WASN'T REALLY COVERED. IT WAS
BECOMING A BIGGER AND BIGGER
ISSUE IS COMPANIES WERE ENGAGED
IN BEHAVIOR THAT QUITE FRANKLY.
AS I'VE SAID SO MANY TIMES WAS
CREEPY. AND ON THE OTHER SAYS
WE NEED DEEPER PRINT SUMMER
PROTECTIONS ON THE OTHER HAND
WE HAD THESE HORRIBLE.
CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO THE
ALL OF THESE VARIOUS BUSINESS
MODELS THAT WERE HAPPENING AND
EVERYBODY WAS GOING CRAZY.
SENATOR DODD WAS INVOLVED IN
THIS HE WAS OF A PRINCIPLE-
JOIN AUTHOR AND ALL THIS STUFF.
THE OTHER THE OTHER WORK ON
SERVICES WERE FINISHED HERE BUT
THE POINT IS. THAT WE MET WE
WERE WE WERE FACED WITH A VERY
DIFFICULT ETHICAL DECISION. DO
WE LET THIS THING CONTINUE TO
GO FORWARD IN IN IN THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH IT SAID
WHERE THEY WERE CLEARLY MORE
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE NEEDED
CLEARLY CHANGE THAT NEED TO BE
MADE. ORDER WE GO BACK TO THE
BALLOT. I DON'T KNOW IF HE SAID
THIS YEAR INTRODUCTION BUT DO
WE GO BACK TO THE BALLOT. AND
THE DECISION WAS MADE I THINK
THE RIGHT DECISION. AND I AND
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF HOURS
WERE SPENT BY NUMBER OF US FOR
MONTHS. GOING THROUGH THIS AND
THE ADVANTAGE WE HAD WAS WE
PRETTY MUCH KNEW WHAT THE
PROBLEMS WERE UNDER C. C. P. A
NUMBER ONE. AND NUMBER TWO ALL
OF US THAT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THIS BOTH ON THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE THE ASSEMBLY. AND
THOSE OF US INVOLVED IN THE
SENATE SENATOR DODD CENTER
JACKSON. HAD HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF COMMENTS
FROM GROUPS ALL ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM. OF IDEAS
THAT THEY HAD SO UNLIKE- WHAT
WE SAW BEFORE WHERE SOMEBODY
COMES IN WHO'S- GOT THE
RESOURCES TO WRITE BUT
SOMETHING ON THE BALLOT. THIS
WAS TWO YEARS OF A YEAR AND A
HALF OF JUST EXTRAORDINARY
AMOUNT OF COMMENTS FROM PEOPLE.
WHERE WE COULD UNDERSTAND WHERE
PEOPLE ARE COMING FROM AND SO
THE PROCESS WAS- WE CAME UP
WITH THIS. AND I GOTTA TELL YOU
I MEAN I IT'S THE HARDEST THING
IN THE YEAR THAT I'VE BEEN A-
WORKED ON. AND I THINK THIS.
ARE THE MOST ELEGANT. I THINK
THAT THERE'S A VERY SIGNIFICANT
COMPROMISES BUT IN THE END OF
THE DAY THE- THE- THE IMPACTS
ON THE- A PROTECTING CONSUMERS
ARE MORE EXPANSIVE. THE
SOPHISTICATION OF MORE DETAILS.
ARM AND MANY OF THE MISTAKES
THAT WE HAD MADE AND WE MADE
THAT MUCH YOU JUST CAN'T WRITE
A BILLS COMPLICATED WITHOUT
MAKING MISTAKES- WERE SCRUBBED.
SO I GOT TO TELL YOU I JUST
WANT TO GIVE. MR TAGGER TO
GREAT- ATTA BOY AND- THANK HIM
FOR CONTINUING YOU KNOW. LAST
THING ALL SURE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MISTER GOING OFF THIS. AND IN
BUFFY YOU WERE INVOLVED IN ALL
THE SERVER WORK. ON ALL THESE
ISSUES AS WELL IN A PRETTY DEEP
WAY. WAS WHAT WAS UNIQUE HERE.
WAS OFTEN SOMEBODY WHO HAS THE
RESOURCES COMES AND PUT
SOMETHING ON THE BALLOT. AND
PUT IT BEFORE THE VOTERS WHICH
YOU HAD HERE WAS SOMEBODY WHO
SPENT THOUSANDS OF HOURS
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY
AFTER- THE INITIATIVE BUT
WORKING HIRING MORE EXPERTS THE
BEST IN THE COUNTRY TRAVELING
WORKING WITH THE EUROPEANS
WORKING WITH PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON DC AND NEW YORK AND
ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY.
CONTINUE TO EDUCATE HIMSELF
CONTINUING TO DO THE HOMEWORK
AND SO THIS WASN'T JUST
SOMETHING THAT WAS DROPPED ON
FOLKS BUT THAT WAS LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF HOURS NOT. FROM THE
DAYS THAT THIS IN MEASURE WAS
ADOPTED ON THE- JUNE WHATEVER
IT WAS NOT TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TILL TODAY MR ME TAG
HAS NOT STOPPED. BEING DEEPLY
ENGAGED IN EVERY ELEMENT. OF
THIS PROCESS IN A VERY
THOUGHTFUL WAY AT A VERY
REASONABLE WAY- AND I THINK
THAT THE- BOTTOM LINE IS IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN CONSUMER FACING IT
EVERY QUESTION EVERY MEASURE.
HI THIS IS PROTECT CONSUMERS.
AND SO I JUST THINK YOU DID A
GREAT JOB AND I. SORRY FOR THE
LONG INTRODUCTION BUT IT'S A
SHORT INTRODUCTION COMPARED TO
THE- HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
HOURS THAT WE DON'T DO DEVOTED
TO THIS. TO TRY TO DEAL WITH
THIS EXCEPTIONALLY COMPLICATED
ISSUE AND MOVING TARGET. AND
I'M HOPEFUL I AS A MEMBER OF
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER I'M
PART OF THE MAJORITY LEADER'S A-
CONFERENCE AS WELL AS- THE-
STATE REGION LEADERS FOUNDATION
AND- NATIONALLY THESE GROUPS
HAVE. CHOSEN TO MAKE PRIVACY
ONE OF THEIR TOP PRIORITIES IN
THEIR LEGISLATOR AWESOME. EMMA
LOOK IS ALL THE COUNTRY. SO I'M
HOLD THAT IN MANY CASE THAT
HAVE. WITH IDEAS IN CALIFORNIA
JUST GOT OFF OF CALL ON BAIL
AND I'M HOPING THAT THAT SETS
THE TONE OF THE FUTURE. AND
THAT WE COULD DO THE SAME
THING. IN THIS VERY DELICATE
ISSUE PRIVACY THE STATE THAT IS
AN INNOVATIVE PLACE THAT IT AT
ITS FOUNDATION. DEALS WITH
INDUSTRY AT THE CORE OF THE
PRIVACY DEBATE IN WITH THAT. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME. I'LL JUST IT'S A
LONG STATEMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SENATOR HERTZBERG- AT
THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO INVITE MY
COLLEAGUES TO- WAS QUESTIONS TO
THE- FIRST TWO PRETTY RECEIVED
THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. ON
THIS WEEK'S GO AHEAD PLEASE
THANK YOU I'M THANK YOU MISTER
ENTIRE FOR COMING AND SPEAKING
AND YOU KNOW I'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS- ON AND OFF OVER THE LAST.
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN OFFICE HERE
AND I. AM A BIG PROPONENT OF
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
PRIVACY AND- ALSO SURE MISTER
HERTZBERG- EIGHT DOLLARS MEANT
THAT THIS IS IT EVER CHANGING
LANDSCAPE. AND IT'S VERY
COMPLICATED AND SOMETIMES IT'S
HARD TO. EXPLAIN TO SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IS HARD PRESSED TO
UNDERSTAND TO MOVE SO QUICKLY
THE TECHNOLOGY CHANGES ALL THE
TIME AND SO WE HAVE TO BE.
ADAPTED TO IT- YOU KNOW AND I
ALSO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE I
KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS WHOLE
PROCESS- I'VE MET WITH MANY
MANY MANY OF THEM OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF. AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
THE BEST. POSSIBLE POLICY
SOLUTION TO IT HERE TO THE GOAL
OF. AND CONSUMER PROTECTION OF
A LOT OF. LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS.
BUT ONE THING I WANTED TO FLAG
I KNOW THAT- LAST YEAR IN
OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR- A
COALITION OF CONSUMER GROUPS
INCLUDED ACLU ANY FF AND-
COMMON SENSE MEDIA AND A BUNCH
OF OTHER FOLKS THAT SENT IN. A
LETTER WITH IT FORTY FIVE
SUGGESTED- CHANGES TO THE
DRAFT- THAT WERE DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THAT THE INITIATIVE TO
NOT ROLL BACK PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ONLY ABOUT
SEVEN OF THOSE WERE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT SORT OF TO SOME DEGREE-
I JUST WONDER IF YOU COULD HELP
EXPLAIN. AND IF IT. IF I'M
WRONG ON THAT THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF IT. BUT IF YOU
CAN HELP EXPLAIN MY MORE OF
THOSE THE COALITION SUGGESTIONS
RUN CORPORATE IN THE FINAL
VERSION OF THE INITIATIVE. AND
ARE IN ARE YOU ALSO STILL
WORKING WITH THOSE FOLKS AND-
YOU KNOW THAT SOMEBODY. PRIVACY
ADVOCATES THAT I TURN TO FOR MY
OWN UNDERSTANDING I TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT- INPUT IS RECEIVED
AND- STILL. WITH AMBER WHAT'S
UP WHAT'S- AND WHAT THEIR
STATUS. TAKE ON A- THIS THANK
YOU. AGAIN ALSO IS A MEMBER OF.
YOUR INTEREST GOOD IT'S BEEN
ABOUT A BIG ONE FOR YOU- YOU'VE
BEEN PASSION ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
INTEREST ISSUE. I DID A ONE.
THIRD COME SO I JUST I TOOK THE-
OF AND I DIDN'T HAVE A- OF TIME
DO ALL BUT- JUST HERE'S A LIST
OF. THAT WE DO TAKE FROM LETTER
WE TO OUT. OTHER SUCH. DISCLOSE
PURPOSES FROM SECTION ONE
HUNDRED. SECTION ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO- WE DID THE SAME
THING FOR PURPOSE LIMITATION
FOR DATA MINIMIZATION WE
CHANGED THE USE RETENTION AND
SHARING. FROM COLLECTIONS. WE
TOOK UP OF SECTION ONE HUNDRED
AND FIVE T. ONE. WE DELETED A
HUNDRED AND FIVE DENIED THESE
ARE ALL THEIR REQUEST YEAH. WE
DIDN'T DELETE- ONE TWENTY FIVE
WE DID INTEREST THAT SECOND
OPTION WHICH- IS. THE KEY. YEAH
IN. THEIR IN PROFILING VICTIM
LIKE THAT WE WERE. TO THE G.
DEFINITION OF PRO. IN THEIR-
BACK. WE TOOK OUT THE- OF. POP
AS DESIGNED. THAT FROM SECURITY
TO. WE TOLD THE CHAIN THE NOT.
EVER TO BE PURELY TO. WITH DEAL
OKAY. REVERTED TO ORIGINAL DE.
OF WONDERS OF. WITH THERE ARE.
OF PUBLICLY AVAILABLE WE DID TO
DELETE THE RESTRICTION ON USE
ONCE RELEASED BY GOVERNMENT I
WAS ONE THERE'S- BUT WE DIDN'T.
REALIZE IS. AT. IN RESPECT THIS
PROVIDE THERE CAN ABOUT COMBINE
PERSONAL. WE STUCK IN A HOLE
CLAUSEN ONE EIGHTY FIVE A
ELEVEN. DESTRUCTIVE AGENCY WITH
RESPECT TO COMBINING. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WAS DONE IN A
WAY TO MAXIMIZE CONSUMER
PRIVACY- WE REMOVE WE TIGHTENED
UP THE AT THERE'S JUST AND ONE
FORTY FIVE A ONE WITH. A VALID
LEGAL. PROCESS WHICH GOT THAT
PHRASE FELL TO GO PROCESS AND
WE MADE IT MUCHMORE
RESTRICTIVE- ONE FORTY FIVE
EIGHT TWO. REGARDING
INVESTIGATION MEANS THAT WE
KNOW OUR- CASE ACTIVE CASE
NUMBER- TO HAVE A- A HIGH
RANKING POLICE OFFICER WITHIN
THREE DAYS YOU NEED TO GO GET A
COURT ORDER BUT- IN. FUNDS CHOP
WELFARE THE BETTER. JEFF EVEN
WANT TO HAVE A OF EMERGED
EXCEPT WE CHANGE AND THE- THEY
DID WANT US TO MAKE THAT
PERMITS SO WE MADE WINDOWS
YEARS SO. BUT THAT'S A PART
LIST OF WE TEAMS THEIR WORK.
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW THE
POINT IS IT'S- YOU NEVER TO
PLEASE EVERYBODY- WE YOU KNOW
AND ONE OF THESE I WILL SAY AND
I SAID IT BEFORE BUT HE'S HERE
NOW. LAST FALL. CENTER
HERTZBERG WITH THEIR MOST OF
THE PHONE CALLS THOUSANDS I
MEAN IN A WITHIN SEVEN WEEKS IT
WAS. A CRAZY AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT WE SPENT. A LOT OF THE
TIME IT'S RELYING ON SOMEONE'S
GOT A TREMENDOUS TRACK RECORD
OF GETTING THINGS DONE AND FOR
SAYING HEY WHERE DO YOU THINK
WE CAN OF WHAT WE'RE IS THAT
WHERE IS THE RIGHT PLACE TO
DRAW THE LINE. YOU KNOW FOR ME
I'M A BIG PER. IS THE ENEMY OF
THE GOOD. PERSON AND I'M TRYING
TO GET SOME THAT WILL STAND THE
TEST OF TIME THAT WILL- THAT
WOULD BE WE CAN ACHIEVE. AND SO
THERE WERE. AND UNFORTUNATELY-
THAT'S LIFE. BUT I WILL SAY.
THAT MY HAT IS OFF THESE ARE
THESE ARE. RELATIVELY SMALL
GROUPS COMPARE THESE GIANT
INDUSTRIES. YOU KNOW IF IT'S
CONSUMER REPORT THREE FF FOR-
IS STILL YOU OR COMMONSENSE.
AND THEY ARE- THEY'RE FIGHTING
FOR JUSTICE THERE FIGHTING FOR-
PRIVACY AND IN MANY RESPECTS. I
COULD HAVE DONE. ANY OF WHAT
I'VE DONE. HAD THEY NOT BEEN
OUT THERE AT THE FOREFRONT FOR
ALL THOSE YEARS TRYING TO.
RAISE THE THESE. IS AND KEEP
THEM- IN IN IN IN. FOUR FIVE
THE- OF PEOPLE'S MINDS SO. MY
HAT IS OFF TO THEM- ALSO PRICE
RATES GREENHOUSE. SHOULD
MENTION THEM- HAS AFTER ALL.
AND THAT'S- THE- THANK YOU FOR
THAT. DO YOU AND HAS THE
GETTING THEIR OFFICIAL. DO YOU
HAVE ANY FIRST INTERVIEW
ANTICIPATEDI'M A I I'VE I'VE-
CHOSEN NOT TO. ANYBODY FOR
THEIR FISH SUPPORT AND I HAVE
THAT BALANCE CENTER I DON'T YOU
KNOW I'M A BIG SORT OF LOOK
FOLLOWING A- AND GET ONE THING
DONE. ONCE WE HAVE WHAT'S WERE
ON THE BALLOT THAT I PLAN TO GO
OUT FOR THEIR PERSONAL SUPPORT
ALL OF THEM YEAH- AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT THEY WOULD. SUPPORT
BECAUSE THIS. AT THIS THIS THIS
WOULD BE. I EVEN STRONGER THE
CPA. I THINK. AGAIN ALL THE
REASONS I WENT THROUGH I WOULD.
I WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL TO
GET ALL SUPPORT. AND IS IT
THANK YOU THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
CONTACTS I APPRECIATE THAT. AND
IS IT YOUR SENSE. THANK I'VE
HEARD ARE THE- POTENTIALLY THIS
CONTROL LIKE SOME OF THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION THIS. IS
THAT YOU'RE TAKING YOU THINKTHIS ACTUALLY STRENGTHENED HIS
ANY CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE WEAKENED WITH THIS
INITIATIVE. WHAT I DISCUSSED I
THINK IT I THINK IS VASTLY
MOVED THE BALLFORWARD ON A
WHOLE BUNCH AREAS I THINK THAT
THERE IS. AND I AND I THINK
THERE'S CONFUSION AROUND THAT
ONE THE SECOND OPTION WE'VE
CREATED WITH THE DO NOT CALL
VERSUS WHERE NOW A COMPANY-
STILL HAS RESPECT OR DO NOT
SELL OPTION BUT- CHOICE IT
DOESN'T. PUT UP A- RESTRICTION
HOWEVER OFTEN CAN'T CHARGE YOU.
CAN DISCRIMINATE AGAINST YOU I
THINK THAT THAT WAS I THINK
WE'RE THE WORLD'S GONNA GO. I
THINK THE ONLY ONE PEOPLE. WANT
TO AND SAY. WELL WHY DO YOU DO
THIS IS THAT SELECT. OF
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. THAT CHANGE.
AND AGAIN AS I SAID WE FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW PROFESSORS
TELL ME SOMETHING. I GOT A LIST
OF THAT THEY WERE UNANIMOUS AND
THEY ALSO DO NEED TO CHANGE
THIS BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T HAVE.
A AN EXEMPTION FOR WHEN
HERTZBERG HANDS OUT- BUT THE
STORY OF HIS TRIP TO CHINA ANY
PASSES IT OUT. OF THAT'S NOT
PERCENT RATIO ANYMORE AND WE
DID WE DON'T HAVE A RIGHT NOW
TO SKIP SO I'M- I'LL TAKE THE
HEAT FOR THAT ONE BUT AND FOR
ME I. MIGHT MY OLD. LAST FIND
THE BEST MINDS I COULD. LIST TO
THEM. TAKE EXPERT ADVICE. AND
YOU'RE TRYING TO LISTEN TO BE
MORE TRANSLATE SOMETHING. AND
THESE PEOPLE OF THE GOODNESS OF
THEIR THAN I DON'T PAY THEM
THEY WERE JUST- PEOPLE WHO
VOLUNTEERED YOU KNOW IN MANY
CASES TENS OR HUNDREDS OF HOURS
TO. REVIEW THIS AND THEY WERE-
CONSISTENT CONSIST ABOUT IT BUT
NO LET ME BE CLEAR. THIS LAW
WOULD DRAMATICALLY STRENGTHEN
CONSUMER PRIVACY CALIFORNIA. IT
WOULD TAKE IT OUT OF THE REACH
OF BEING. HURT BY A FUTURE
LEGISLATURE THAT WANTED TO. IT
WOULD SET A STRONG MESSAGE NASH.
I THINK THIS WOULD. KLAY BUT-
I'M JUST BLOCK. ACTIVE IN THE-
AND THE PEOPLE ASSUME TO BE
OURS ONE COUNTRY YOU KNOW FOR
ONE LAW IS NOT SIMPLY TO BUY
EVERY SINGLE COUNTRY WHERE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY THE WORLD
WILLHAVE ONE REGULATOR
REGULATING THIS WE WILL
SUDDENLY BECOME I THINK THE
MOST IMPORTANT PRIVACY PLAYER.
IN THE WORLD. ALSO THANK YOU.
BOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MAYBE
I GOT PASSED NIGHT NEXT
QUESTION ALL I THINK YOU
TOUCHED ON THIS BRIEFLY ALSO
MISTER MCTAGGART ARM THE
INITIATIVE PERMITS THE
PROVISIONS OF THE ACT TO BE
AMENDED BY THE LEGISLATURE WITH
A SIMPLE MAJORITY UP HERE FOR
THE AMENDMENTS ARE CONSISTENT
WITH AND FOR HER TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY. OTHERWISE IT WOULD
REQUIRE VOTER APPROVAL THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU
ANTICIPATE OF THE PHRASE IN
FURTHERANCE OF- TO BE
INTERPRETED AND DEEP HOW DO YOU
ENVISION THAT PROVISION TO
AFFECT THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
THANK. EDUCATION BECAUSE OF
THAT TERM OR WILL IMPEDE TO
LEGISLATORS ABILITY TO RESPOND
TO THE DIFFERENT CONSTITUENTS
NEEDS A BY CHANGING THE LAW. IF
YOU NEED ME TO REPEAT REPEAT
QUESTOR AND SO LET ME START BY
A HERE'S THE HERE'S ONE OF THE
I THINK IT REALLY IMPORTANT
PHRASES FROM THAT SECTION. THAT
CONSUMER PRIVACY IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF BENEFICIAL NEW
PRODUCTS AND SERVICE ARE NOT
NECESSARILY INCOMPATIBLE GOALS.
PROVIDED AMENDMENTS DON'T
COMPROMISE OR WE CAN CONSIDER
PRIVACY. SO SOME HAVE TO DRAW A
LINE AND YOU HAVE TO SERICE
YOU HAVE TO SAY THIS TO PLEASE
YOU CAN'T SO THAT'S OUR OUR
THRUSH YOU KNOW THAT. CALM
WINDS ARE WE CAN CAN. YOU CAN
HAVE THIS IS A OLD. DECK FOR ME.
AND MY ANSWER THAT IS. LOOKING
IT'S- A LOT BETTER THAN NOTHING
WHICH IS WHAT WE HAVE NOW THE
GREAT OTHER NO PROTECTIONS AND
SO FUTURE LEGISLATURE TO COME
IN WITHOUT YOU. MEMBERS HERE
WHO. IN THIS AND THEY COULD
CHANGE ALL OF THE STRIP IT OUT
PUT IT OUT OF EXISTENCE. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT THE- WHEN MEMBERS
PROPOSED BILLS. THE CONSULTANTS
IN THE IN THE- COMMITTEES.
PERFORM A KIND OF A- HIGH LEVEL
ANALYSIS AND THEY'LL- I THINK
IT WILL BE QUITE. QUICKLY
PRETTY SIMPLE AS TO WHETHER
SOMETHING IS OR IS NOT YOU KNOW
COULD HURT CONSUMER PRIVACY.
YES AT THE END OF THE DAY IF.
WERE IN SHE WOULD END UP THE
COURT BUT- AGAIN THAT'S NOT THE
WORLD IT'S A LOT BETTER
CONSTRUCT. VAN PROTECTION.
SOMETHING MISTER. IN THIS THIS
IN THIS INITIATIVE AND
BASICALLY ALMOST EVERY
INITIATIVE. YOU KNOW IN THE
STEM CELL THEY'VE GOT A SUPER
MAJORITY TO MAKE CHANGES IF YOU
LOOK TO THE HISTORY OF ALL
THESE INITIATIVES HAVE BEEN PUT
ON THE BALLOT. AND LITIGATION
IF YOU KNOW THAT HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS WHOLE CONCEPT
OF IN FURTHERANCE OF IS ALWAYS
CHALLENGING IT'S ALWAYS
CHALLENGING AND- IF YOU GO ON
PERHAPS THE STATUTORY AS
OPPOSED TO A CONSTITUTIONAL
INITIATIVE I THINK YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE GOT
ISSUE THERE SO IF YOU DON'T PUT
IN FURTHERANCE LANGUAGE IT'S
PROBLEMATIC OF THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY'S WANTED TO HAVE TWO
THIRDS VOTE BECAUSE THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT. THE LEGISLATURE
PASSING A- OF A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION WHICH IS YOU KNOW WAS
A BIG QUESTION IT WAS A BIG
QUESTION THAT LETTER. AND HE
DECIDED NOT TO DO WHAT I WAS
FAVOR BUT EITHER THAT WAS THE
ONLY REASON WE GOT A PRIVACY
DEAL BECAUSE OF. THE REASON IT
WAS WRONG. TO THIS INSTITUTION
IT EVERY BONE IN MY BODY TO
MAKE A DEAL AND THEN. BEFORE
THE INK IS DRY TO THEN GO AND
GO BACK ON THE DEAL. BUT
CERTAINLY THAT'S GOING TO BE
LITIGATED CERTAINLY I SUSPECT
FUTURE LEGISLATURE WILL DO THAT
AND THAT WILL BE LITIGATED AND
THAT'S ALWAYS THE CASE. BUT IT
BUT- PROBABLY IN TERMS OF
NEGOTIATION THE MOST. ELEMENTS
HERE BECAUSE- HOW DO YOU DEAL
WITH THE VACATION. HOW TO DEAL
WITH ALL THESE OTHER ISSUES.
AND I PROBABLY OF ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE WORKED ON THIS
IN FURTHERANCE LANGUAGE IF YOU
READ THE SECTIONS WAS SECTION
SEE OR SOMETHING PAGE THREE.
MEMBERS CORRECT. THAT LAST
WHICH IS VERY VERY VERY
SENSITIVE AND- REALLY TRYING
TO. HELLO THE WAY THAT WE DO.
ALL OF PRIVACY ON THE ONE HAND.
YET DON'T MAKE THE ENTIRE ISSUE
THE INITIATIVE MEANINGLESS SO
THAT NEXT YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
COMES O AND JUST TOTALLY FLIPS
IT. BECAUSE THERE WAS SO MUCH
ARCHITECTURE IN THIS. AND
TRYING TO MAKE IT WORK SO. I
CAN SAY IS I JUST. BUT BUT IT'S
BEEN A- IT'S BEEN SUCH A BIG
ISSUE ON SO MANY INITIATIVES
THAT I WORKED ON OF THE LAST
DECADES. ARM THAT THAT'S ALWAYS
THE CORE AND I THINK THAT THE
BALANCE THAT WAS STRUCK AND
THIS. WAS QUITE ELEGANT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH UP. SO I THINK
I'M GONNA ASSAM AND MISSED MY
COGNITIVE STATE UP FRONT FOR
THE QUESTIONS. AND AT THIS TIME
I I'M GONNA. ARE GOOD A SECOND
PANEL- IF THAT'S OKAY LET'S SEE.
THE BACK THANK YOU REALLY THANK.
BECAUSE NO GROUP'S SELF
FORMALLY OPPOSED OR SUPPORTED
THIS INITIATIVE MEASURE OF THIS
PANEL IS MADE UP BUT THIS NEXT
PANEL IS MADE OF WHAT WE ARE
CALLING INTERESTED PARTIES-
FIRST WE'LL HEAR FROM CONSUMER
ADVOCACY TO HELP OUR- IN
MINUTES MONEY FOLLOW BY
INDUSTRY REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
ALSO BEEN. A FIFTY. AFTER THE
PANELISTS HAVE I WILL OPEN IT
UP FOR THE MEMBERS- TO QUESTION
THEM I ASKED THAT ALL PANELISTS
REMAIN AVAILABLE AFTER THING-
CONCLUSION OF THEIR INDIVIDUAL
TESTIMONY FOR QUESTIONS AND
DISCUSSION. SO LET'S GO WITH-
NOW NEXT TO PANEL FROM CONSUMER
REPORTS WE HOW OFTEN IS MAUREEN
MAHONEY- MISTER MAHONEY I YOU
WITH THANK YOU THANK THANKS FOR
JOINING US SO FIRST OF ALL. AND
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
PROCEED. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
MY NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY I'M
A POLICY ANALYST AT CONSUMER
REPORTS AND I CAN SEE MORE
PORTS WE REALLY WAITED THAT
JANUARY FIRST IMPLEMENTS.
COUNTY OF THE CITY PA WHEN
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
FIRST TIME WE GET IMPORTANT
BASELINE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
IN LIGHT OF FEDERAL IN ACTION.
BUT AS THE LAW WENT INTO EFFECT
TO BE. CLEAR THAT YOU NEED TO
BE STRENGTHENS GIVEN WIDESPREAD
NONCOMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW. THE
BIGGEST DATA COLLETOR IS LIKE
GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK DECLARE
THAT THEIR DATA SHARING WAS
OUTSIDE OF THE OPT OUT OF SALEM
EMBOLDENED BY WE CAN FORSMAN
PROVISIONS. COMPANIES EXPLOITED
LOOPHOLES TO CONTINUE TO
DELIVER CROSS EYED CROSS DEVICE
TARGET ADVERTISING. YOU KNOW
GIVING CONSUMERS CONTROL OVER
THIS KIND OF DATA SHARING WAS
ONE OF THE PRIMARY PURPOSES OF
THE CCPA. AND SO MANY COMPANIES
HAVE SIZE UP THE CZ PEERING WE
ARE PLEASED THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY RIGHTS ACTS WOULD CLOSE
UP TARGET ADVERTISING
LOOPHOLES. STRENGTHEN
ENFORCEMENT AND HELP PREVENT
THE LEGISLATURE FROM WEAKENING
THE MEASURE. AT THE SAME TIME
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE
BALLOT INITIATIVE INTRODUCES
NEW AMBIGUITIES AND GLASSES
CERTAINLY POLLS LIKE ALLOWING
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO COMBINE
DATA RECEIVED FROM MULTIPLE
COMPANIES. AND FINALLY PRIVACY
IS A RIGHT NOT SOMETHING THAT
CONSUMERS SHOULD BE CHARGED FOR
SO WE THINK IT'S A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY TO CLARIFY THAT
PRIVACY ISN'T JUST SOMETHING
THAT THE RICH SHOULD ENJOY. SO
GOING TO THESE POINTS IN A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL. THE FIRST
THE BALLOT INITIATIVE WOULD CAN
GIVE CONSUMERS ETTER CONTROL
OVER TARGETED ADVERTISING- IN
THIS IS TO BE THE DEFINITION OF
SALE AND THE SERVICE PROVIDER
EXEMPTION HAVE BEEN EXPLOITED
BY COMPANIES TO CONTINUE TO
DELIVER THESE ADS OUTSIDE THE
OPT OUT. WITH RESPECT TO THE
DEFINITION OF SALE EVEN THOUGH
IT IS A REALLY BROAD DEFINITION
OF SALES SOME COMPANIES HAVE
CLAIMED THAT BECAUSE MONEY IN
AND DAY DARKNESS BEING
EXCHANGED. IT'S NOT A SALE-
WHAT HAPPENS IS MONEY IN DATA
OFTEN FLOWS IN THE SAME
DIRECTION TO I TECH PLATFORMS
TO SHOW ADS ON MULTIPLE SITES
THE SERVICE WRITER EXEMPTION.
HAS ALSO BEEN EXPLOITED-
PUBLISHERS ARE SAYING THAT THEY
CAN SHARE DATA- WITH HUNDREDS
OF DIFFERENT COMPANIES TO
DELIVER ADVERTISING AS PART OF
A SERVICE PROVIDER
RELATIONSHIPS THEY'LL BE
OUTSIDE THE OPT OUT. SO THE
BALLOT INITIATIVE WOULD-
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY CREATING
THIS NEW CATEGORY OF SHARING
THAT CONSUMERS WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OPT OUT OF
EXPOSING CLARIFIES THAT CROSS
CONTEXT TARGET ADVERTISING. IS
PART OF THAT SO CONSUMERS COULD
OPT OUT. AND THE SERVICE WRITER
EXEMPTION IS SIGNED UP BY
EXCLUSIVELY CLARIFYING THAT
CROSS CONTEXT TARGET
ADVERTISING ISN'T OP
PERMISSIBLE BUSINESS PURPOSE-
SO IT'S REMOVED FROM THE
SERVICE WRITER. EXEMPTION IN
OUR OPINION HOW THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE WOULD MEANINGFULLY
STRENGTH IN ENFORCEMENT
PARTICULARLY BY REMOVING THIS
RIGHT TO CURE PROVISION IN
ADMINISTRATIVE ENFORCEMENT
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY. I GET OUT
OF JAIL FREE CARD- FEELS I
THINK THE CREATING A NEW AGENCY
THAT'S EXCLUSIVELY DEVOTED TO
IMPLEMENTING AND ENFORCING THIS
LAW- COULD HELP PUT SOME TEETH
BEHIND THE MEASURE AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE. THAT THIS DOES ALL
LIMIT THE LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY
TO WEEKEND. THE LAW. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THE BALLOT SHOULD OF
INTRODUCES SOME LESS THAN IDEAL
ELEMENTS IN SOME CASES WEAKER
THAN EXISTING LAW. FOR EXAMPLE
A CREATE A NEW CONFUSING
EXEMPTION FOR SHARING PERSONAL
DATA WITH CONTRACTORS BEYOND
WHAT'S ALREADY A LOT FOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS. IT ALSO
CREATES OF COMPLETED MECHANISM
FOR CONSUMERS TO OPT OUT OF
SHARING OR SALE- SO THIS IS ONE
OF OUR TOP PRIORITY IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A UNIVERSAL
OPT OUT SO CONSUMERS DON'T HAVE
TO GO TO EVERY SINGLE COMPANY
TO OPT OUT OF JAIL. FOR SHARING
INFORMATION- WITH MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED STATE WORKERS ON
THE CALIFORNIA DATA BROKER
REGISTRY ALONE NOT TO MENTION.
THE HUNDREDS OF OTHER COMPANIES
THAT ARE COLLECTING CONSUMERS
STATE. IF THEY'RE GONNA OPT OUT
ONE BY ONE THIS IS COMPLETELY
UNWORKABLE- ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THAT SOME COMPANIES HAVE MADE
CONSUMERS JUMP THROUGH HOOPS IN
ORDER TO OPT OUT- ONE DATA FOR
THIS. CATION DATA DOWN. A
SEPARATE HOW TO MY PHONE- JUST
ARTICLE ONCE- SO- YOU KNOW ONE
CONSUMER TOLD ME THEY COULD
EVEN COMPLETE ONE OPT OUT
BECAUSE IT WAS TOO MUCH WORK.
MAKING A SIMPLE SIMMERS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THE CALL
ATTORNEY RULES ARE CLEAR THAT
THEY WERE COME HAVE A GLOBAL DO
NOT SELL SIGNAL IN CONTRAST
ABOUT INITIATIVE MANDATES THE
COMPANIES THAT DO NOT WANT TO
PUT UP I DO NOT SO LINK MUST
UNDERGO POPPED UP TODAY TERRY
AS TO WHETHER OTHER COMPANIES
WOULD HAVE. THAT AT LEAST SOME
REPORTERS AND LAW FIRMS ARE
INTERPRETING THAT IS OPTIONAL-
SO IDEALLY CONSUMERS WHEN HAVE
TO OPT OUT IN THE FIRST PLACE
OF THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
WOULD BE. AUTOMATIC BUT AT THE
VERY LEAST THIS OP DOC SHOULD
BE VERY CLEAR AND SIMPLE AND
THE BALANCE OF ITS A BIGGER SO
FAST. SECONDS THE BILL
INITIATIVE IMPROPERLY LAWS
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO COMBINE
DATA- RECEIVE FROM OTHER
COMPANIES SERVICE WRITERS
SHOULD BE WORKING FOR JUST ONE
COMPANY AT A TIME WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SIR THE WRITERS
THIS COULD BE GOOGLE THIS ME
FACEBOOK- SALES FORCE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED TO. FILL
THESE HUGE CROSS A DATA SIDES
JUST WHILE THE RULES AND ALLOWS
THEM TO DROP IN MORE DETAIL
INSIGHTS INTO CONSUMERS. AND
FINALLY THE BALLOT SHOULD HAVE
MRS A KEY OPPORTUNITY TO.
REMOVE INAPPROPRIATE LANGUAGE
FROM THE C. CPA THAT COULD
ALLOW COMPANIES TO CHARGE
CONSUMERS FOR EXERCISING THEIR
PRIVACY RIGHTS- THIS WAS
PARTICULARLY DISAPPOINTING FOR
US- I CONSUMER REPORTS WE WERE
ABLE TO DEVELOP- CONSENSUS
LANGUAGE. WITH RETAILERS IN
WASHINGTON STATE FOR THEIR
WASHING A PRIVACY ACT- THROUGH
CLARIFY THAT- PURSUANT TO
LOYALTY PROGRAMS- THAT. DATA
CAN BE SOLD WITH THIRD PARTIES.
SO WE'RE CURRENTLY IS OF WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE WE THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD ADDRESS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US
ON. OUR NEXT TO ON THE LINE WE
HAVE MERRY ROSS FROM M. S. R.
STRATEGIES- MISS ROSS ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. YES I AM CAN YOU
HEAR ME I YES WE COULD HEAR YOU
I THANK YOU FOR JOINING US- SO
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU MADE.
A BEGIN. OUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY MY
NAME IS MERRY STONE ROCK. I
WOULD FORMALLY PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY. ONE OF THE CO AUTHORS
OF THE INITIATIVE THAT BECAME
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT. AND ALTHOUGH I DON'T SPEAK
ON THEIR BEHALF TODAY I AM ALSO
A MEMBER OF. THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE. FOR THE ANTI TYPE
AND PRIVATE DETECTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
I AM HERE TODAY MY PERSONAL
CAPACITY IS A PRIVACY ADVOCATE.
AND HAVING THE TCPA THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING TRULY
REMARKABLE. HE CREATED THE
FIRST ROBUST PRIVACY LAW IN THE
NATION. OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND DEDICATED STAFF HAVE SPENT
THE LAST YEAR CAREFULLY
DRAFTING CLEAR AND CONCISE
WILL. CAN FORCE THAT REMARKABLE
LOT. PDPA ENFORCEMENT GOES INTO
EFFECT JULY FIRST. HERE THE
PRIVACY OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD IS
SAFER AND THE- OF YOUR CARD.
WORK. WE DO NOT NEED ALL OF
YOUR HARD BUT- A LAW DOWN HOW
SEEK. WELL TO THE EAST PS. THAT
CURRENTLY BUT DC PETE E. P. R.
A. I DID THE CONSUMER. RIGHTS
ESTABLISHED THE TPP BY. DE
UNDERMINING ENFORCEMENT AND
CREATING NEW RIGHT THAT SOUNDS
GOOD IN CAMPING IN SLOGANS BUT
WILL HAVE LITTLE PRACTICAL
CONSEQUENCE. THE NEWS REPORTING
ON THE TV ARE A HAS BEEN
FRUSTRATING FOR ME TO READ.
THAT ARTICLE TITLED INSIDE THE
CLOSED DOOR CAMPAIGN REWRITE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY LAW AGAIN.
PUBLISHED ON FEBRUARY SIXTH
TWENTY TWENTY. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE DOCUMENT HELP GOOGLE
FACEBOOK EXPERIENCE TWITTER.
OTHER ENTRIES BAD BEHAVIOR THE
FLIGHTS BUT THE CHECK BLOBBY MR
MAKE TIGER FOR EXEMPTION. IT
WORK. INDUSTRIES HAD BEEN HIT
IMPLEMENTED THE CLEARANCE
THROUGHOUT THE SECOND. AND
FINAL VERSION OF THE INITIATIVE
FROM ELIMINATING THE WORD
ENFORCEMENT FROM THE TITLE IN A
MORE REASONABLE IS. TYPE IN THE
NEW. AGENCIES BUDGET. AND
CONTRACT ONLY SEVEN OF THE
PRIVACY COALITION IF I GET THE
CHANGES. CORPORATE. TO CREATE A
NEW CATEGORY IN RIGHT THE
CHARACTERS THE PERSON ON. AND
THE CREATION OF THE ENFORCEMENT.
PRIVATELY BUT WHICH FANTASY AND
NOT TENTATIVE INFORMATION OF
OUR IN THE BLUE THREE WITH THAT
FIRST DROP OF THE TEETH R. A.
GREAT TO THE TEN RATE TO A
CONSUMER OVER THERE CENTER
PERSONAL. UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT
WHICH WERE HAVE. BEEN THE KEY
TO. IN THE FINAL VERSION I BEEN
THAT WOULD BE ON THE NUMBER
BALLOT IF IT QUALIFIES.
ENFORCEMENT THE KEY TO ANY.
PRIVATE LAW I. STATED A NEW THE-
THAT RELATIVELY WEAK IN FORT
SICK. BY AND WE THE RIGHT OF
ACTION. IN THE RIGHT THE DID
ATTORNEY INSIDIOUS. AT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ENFORCEMENT IS
NEGLIGIBLE CLIENTS PAY FOR
LEGAL RISK ASSESSMENT AND HAVE
LIMITED COMPLIANCE BUDGET. BY
AND ENFORCEMENT GIVEN THE CPA
CHANCE TO WORK THAN TO GET. I
AGREE WITH THE AUTHORS THAT
CALIFORNIA NEED THE DATA
PROTECTION AGENCY UNFORTUNATELY
THIS ONE IN THE WORLD FULLY
UNDER FUNDED. KEEPER TIGER THE
FINAL VERSION ONLY REQUIRED
GENERAL FUND OF THE STATE GRANT
AGENCY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THIS. YEAR ALL AFTER EFFECTIVE
THE AGENCIES AT TEN MILLION
FOR. AT THE QUEEN OF THE- ASKED
THE IN BUDGET AS WELL TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AND IT YEAH
IT'S STILL IN. MOVING ON TV ARE
A FURTHER DELAY IT PROTECTION
COLOR WHERE. AND I WONDER
WHETHER WE YOU WILL IN FACT THE.
THE DPRK EXTENDING FOR AND
BUSINESS BUSINESS CAN. UNTIL
JANUARY TWO TWENTY. THAT WOULD
WORTH THE FUNDS THAT ON JANUARY
THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE
ARE NUMEROUS THE- WHERE REALLY
WORKERS OUTSIDE THE NORMAL OF
THE IN PLAIN. INCLUDING THROUGH
TRACKING AND MONITORING. EVEN
MORE. AND. FROM HOME TO COPE AT
NIGHT I'M IT BUT THE P. R.
EIGHT TO THE OFFICE AND WILL
EXACT FROM FUTURE FOR MARK. HE
WROTE AND DATABASE STRENGTHENED
THE TCPA THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TAKE IT WILL BE A WILL A CO.
FOR UNDERMINE THE EXISTING RULE
NO A BUT WHICH WHETHER TREE TO
SIGNAL TYPICALLY FIFTEEN TELL
MY IN LINK CURRENTLY IN PC IT
BY THE ROLE REQUIRED A BIT
COULD YOU. A NEW INITIATIVE
CREATES USUALLY CALLED
WEAKENING SOME OF THE CORD
AFTER AND SO PROVIDER PUBLICLY
OF DE I DON'T IN A CONSUME
REQUEST IT ON EXPANDED THEM
INCLUDE FOR SURE CHRIS
INFORMATION WITH BOND. AND
RESEARCH FOR COMMERCIAL PURPOSE
WE YOUR CONSENT. AS YOU KNOW
WELL PRIVATE LEGISLATION
COMPLICATE. IT SHOULD BE NICK.
THROUGH THE WEB. SO THAT ALL.
HAVE A G. TO BE HER. AND VOTED
IN A LOT ELECT OFFICIALS IN TO
THE- WHO WROTE THEM INTO OUT OF.
THANK YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ENTER YOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR ALSO ARE TESTING FINAL AMONG.
CONSUMER ABBOTT WE HAVE ARE
REAL JOHN FOR COMMON SENSE
MEDIA IS JOHN ARE YOU ON LINE.
YES I AM GOOD MORNING THE MORE.
I WELCOME AND YOU WHICH I US
TODAY AND TIME YOUR YOU MAY UP
THE- THANK YOU OF CHAIRMAN
SHALL. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS OUTSIDE JOHNSON AND
I'M ACCOUNT FOR PA AND YET
SENSE MEDIA. WERE A SPONSOR THE
CAL. CAN PRATT ACT. THANK YOU
HOLDING THE HEARING AND FOR
ALLOWING US TO PER. INCLUDING
ME BY. AT PANTERAS OF THE- WAY
I'VE ALREADY KNOW WAS IT'S-
ALLEGES SO. TO A- PRIVACY AND-
WE TAKE SPECIAL. IN THE CURRENT.
INITIATIVE AND A WORLD EVERY
FAMILY HAS THE FORCED ON. IF
THEY'RE LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE
INTERNET. TO GET HEALTHCARE AT.
ENTER WITH FOR. MAKE PURCHASES
AND OF GOD SERVICE. IT IS MORE
AND THAN EVER THAT PRIVATE IS
PRETTY. FAMILIES HAVE TO READ
PER AND MAKE LET'S TRY. THEY
NEED STE DEFAULT. AND TO BE
ABLE TO GO ABOUT WHAT QUALIFIES
AS LIKE DAYS WITHOUT WERE. THAT
THEY'RE AND THEY CHILDREN EVERY
ONLINE. IS BEING FED AND
ADVERTISING FOR OR OTHER BLACK
BY DETERMINE. BACK LABEL LIMIT
THAT. BE ABLE THE INITIATIVE
WHAT IT. PRIVACY A NUMBER OF.
IT ALSO FALLS OF PROVIDING NEED
PROTECTION DEVELOPER AND BUT-
BE. CERTAIN PRODUCTION. WE ARE
THAT THE INITIATIVE WOULD BE AS
WE IT FOR A ON AND FOR.
IMPORTANT AND MAKE IT ATTORNEY
JOB EASIER REMOVING OUT. ON A
OPINIONS I'M NOT PERMITTING FOR
TO CARE IT OPENS UP THE
POSSIBILITY OF AN FOURTH BY
LOOK GOVERNMENT. THE WATER NOT
OFFER A FULL PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION IT DOESN'T AND THE BILL
TO SAY. AND CASES DATA WHEN
PASSWORDS AND SECURITY QUESTION
ARC. AND CONSUMERS ARE TOO
OFTEN READ PASSWORDS THAT MULTI
SERVICES AND BUSINESSES USED
SAME IF NOT I DON'T SECURITY. I
THINK A BRIDGE CAN TAKEN MULTI
TIMES. RENTS MUST GO BEYOND TO
NOTICE AND CONSENT IF ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE TO BE BASED ON THE
CONCEPT THAT CAN THANK MUST BE
MEANINGFUL. THE INITIATIVE
WOULD CLARIFY THE CONTENT MUST
BE FREELY GIVEN SPECIFIC
INFORMED UNAMBIGUOUS AND
CONTENT DOESN'T COUNT IF IT IS
TO GENERAL TERMS OR PAINTER
DARK PATTERN. WE THINK FUNDING
AND IN THIRD ALSO A STEP
FORWARD WE ARE NOT AGAINST
WHETHER NEW AGENCY OR BETTER.
OFF WITHIN THE OF. IT'S PAST.
ADDRESS THAT BUT I THERE'S
ADEQUATELY OF FUN. CERTAINLY
IT'S MORE THAN THE DATA QUO.
BUT TEN NINE DOLLARS IS WHAT
THAN HALF OF WHAT THE OUR
PRIVATE THE REGULAR IN YOUR POP
FOR THEIR POP. IN SOME PLACES
IN. MRS MARK. RUSSIA CONCERN AT
THIS IS TO BECOME AND THE LAW
OF THE LAND. THAT POINT NOT
MUCH HAPPENED A YEAR IN THE
PAST OF THE STANDARD. IT'S HARD
TO BELIEVE THAT A LOT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN FALLING INITIATIVE.
WE GOT TO GO ABOUT THE TO
MANAGE THAT INDIVIDUALS MAY
DISAGREE ABOUT WHAT IS PRO
PRIVACY. AS THE INITIATIVE
EXPLICITLY STATE THAT
AMENDMENTS SHOULD BE MADE WITH
ATTENTION TO THE IMPACT AND
BUSINESS INNOVATION SO LONG OF
PRIVACY IS NOT WE GET. IN TERMS
SAID I BELIEVE CONTINUE TO HEAR
RECENTLY AS THIS WEEK. THAT
THIS BILL IT WOULD IMPROVE
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHTS FOR MINOR.
THE BILL DOES OFFER NEW SEVEN
PROTECT. THE FOR WANT TO BUILD
AND TEENS IT INCREASE PENALTIES
FOR BY. INCLUDE THEM. BUT DOES
NOT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CHAT AND
TEAMS THAT HAVE A GREAT. ALSO
PROTECTION DRUNKEN DOT
COLLECTION AND INTERFACE. WHAT
INCLUDING DATA MEN. AT ALL A
STEP FORWARD. WE APPRECIATE THE
DUTY TO MINIMIZE EXTENDS TO
COLLECTION USE PROTECTION AND
SHARING A DUTY TO MINIMIZE
SHOULD BE TIED TO A CONSUMERS
REASONABLE EXPECTATION. NOT TO
BUSINESSES PURPOSE WHICH A
CONSUMER MAY NOT UNDERSTAND OR
FRANKLY EVEN BE AWARE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS'S BELL
THREE ONE ONE NINE WHAT A
PROVIDED STRONGER PROTECTION
HERE. THERE ARE ALSO NUMEROUS
NO EXCEPTIONS THAT ALLOW
COMPANIES TO IGNORE CONSUMER
CLASS BASED ON COMPANY
DETERMINE DECISIONS ABOUT
SECURITY AND INTEGRITY
DISPROPORTIONATE EFFORT OR
TRADE SECRETS. THIS COULD
CURTAIL CONSUMER THE TIME TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO DELETE
AND RIGHT NOW INTENTIONALLY
WEAKENING CURRENCY CPA. AND
CERTAIN DEFINITION HAVE BEEN
CHANGED IN WAYS THAT DO NOT
ADVANCE CONSUMER PRIVACY ONE
THAT HAD TAKEN UP A LOT OF TIME
SO FAR IS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION. I'VE NOTED THIS
FALLS OUTSIDE OF ANY PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS UNDER THE LAW. AND
IT TO BE MUCH MORE BROADLY
DEFINED. UNDER THE INITIATIVE
THE TVPA DEFINED PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE AS WAFFLING MADE
AVAILABLE BY THE GOVERNMENT IS
NOT INCLUDING BIOMETRICS. UNDER
THE INITIATIVE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INCLUDE QUOTE
INFORMATION BUSINESS HAS A
REASONABLE BASIS TO BELIEVE IS
LAWFULLY MADE AVAILABLE TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC I THE CONSUMER
OR FROM WIDELY DISTRIBUTED
MEDIA. OR BY THE CONSUMER. OR
INFORMATION MADE AVAILABLE BY A
PERSON TO WHOM THE CONSUMER HAD.
TO THEY BROUGHT IN SOME WHAT
CAN TO. AND WE WERE THAT A LOT
OF. IN INVER LEISURE ONLINE BY
CAN SEE COULD BE EVEN UPPER.
FOR ENABLING KLAY STYLE
SCRAPING THE PROFILE BUILDING
IT THE MORE HAS NOT THAT
THERE'S CRACK. AND
CONSTITUTIONAL CAN. ARE BETTER
DRESSED THROUGH JOHN AND OTHER.
SUCH AS A AGREE TO BUY AND
GROUP LAST YEAR THAT WHAT HAS
ALLOWED. BILL TO AND
INFORMATION INTENT MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. SIMMER BE A MATCH MEDIA.
ULTIMATELY AS YOU'RE HEARING
TODAY THEN DOES NUMBER OF
THINGS IN THE AREA CONSUMER.
AND WE'RE PLEASED WITH THAT
ASPECT OF IT THAT ARE STEP
FORWARD AT THE SAME TIME WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE INITIATIVE
WANT ADEQUATELY PROTECT
CONSUMERS INCLUDING CHILDREN
AND TEENS. AND I'M THE GUY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MUST CONTINUE
TO BE DONE GEN AND I THINK
PRIVACY WHETHER THIS INITIATIVE
ENACTED OR NOT FOR YEARS TO
COME. THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
TO THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
A CHANCE AND FOR YOUR- OUR NEXT
WILL. FROM OUR- REPRESENTATIVES.
WITH THE RACHEL MICHELIN OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. AND SHE HAS JOINED
US IN PERSON TODAY AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US- THIS A
MICHELIN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M RACHEL
MICHELIN PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND IWANNA THANK
YOU. YOUR STAFF IN THE
SERGEANTS HERE FOR MAKING THIS
I'M HERE IMPOSSIBLE TODAY. WITH
THIS BODY PASSED THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THE RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION WAS VERY
APPRECIATIVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND PARTICULARLY
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
HERTZBERG M. MISTER DODD. TAKE
THE INITIATIVE OFF THE BALLOT.
WE BELIEVE THAT LEGISLATION AND
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS
BEFORE A BOWL TO ANY INITIATIVE
THAT LOCKS THE LOT IN. WITH
VIRTUALLY NO ABILITY TO BE A-
THE END OF THE HEINZ EASY P.
WHICH STARTED WITH A COP PARTY
COM. WITH I BY OTHER ISSUES
WERE MAKING HEADLINES HAVE
LITTLE TO DO WITH RETAILERS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
INFORMATION WE HAVE IS ABOUT
OUR CUSTOMERS. THOSE ARE
PURCHASE GOODS OR SERVICES FOR
MATH. CCPA PUTS THE BRUNT OF
THE REGULATION ON CONSUMER
FACING BUSINESSES. EVEN THOUGH
THE PREPONDERANCE OF DATA
PROCESSING IS DONE BY OTHERS.
SYRIAN HAVE ALWAYS CONCERN.
ABOUT PROTECTING THE PRIVACY OF
OUR CUSTOMERS OUR ENTIRE SIX
ASSN RETAIL WITH THE
COMPETITION IS BASED ON OUR
CONSUMER RELATIONSHIPS. AT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF INFORMATION WE
HAVE IS ABOUT OUR CUSTOMERS AND
WHAT THEY PURCHASE AND THE
SERVICES THEY GET. BUT THEIR
CCPA PUTS THE BRUNT OF
REGULATION OUR CUSTOMER FACING
BUSINESSES EVEN THOUGH THINGS
ARE DONE BY OTHER PEOPLE. SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF CCPA RETAILERS
HAVE SPENT TENS OF MILLIONS
MORE DOLLARS WORKING ON
COMPLIANCE AND THAT SPENDING
CONTINUES NOW THAT THE AGES
REGULATIONS HAVE BEEN FINALIZED.
MEMBERS ARE NOT ANTI PRIVACY WE
ARE ALREADY SUBJECT TO THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE. I WAS THE LAWS
IN THE NATION CCPA BUT WE ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE C.
P. R. EIGHT BECAUSE IT IS A
FLEXIBLE AND IT WILL BE
EXPENSIVE. FOR THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTORS AT A TIME WHEN
WE CAN ILL AFFORD IT. SEE IF
YOU'RE A HAVE A PROVISION THAT
ONLY PROVIDES FOR AMENDMENTS
WHICH ARE CONSISTENT WITH AND
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
INITIATIVE. WELL THIS SOUNDS
APPEALING ON ITS FATE. IT
DOESN'T ALLOW FOR ANY
FLEXIBILITY WHICH COULD BE
NEEDED AS TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS FOR
CRISIS DEMANDS. THIS IS NERVOUS.
BEING. I DO AND NGUYEN CPR IS
DRAFTED WE DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT
THE NINETEEN. WE DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT SOCIAL DISTANCING. WE
COULD HAVE COMPREHENDED A TIME
WHEN WALKING INTO THE CAPITAL
WE WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
HEALTH SCREENING FOR HAVE A
TEMPERATURE TAKEN. MOST OF US
HAD NEVER TALKED ABOUT CONTACT
TRACING. AND I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT CONTACT
TRACING IN PARTICULAR. BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
PRIVACY WITH THOSE WITH CONTACT
TRACING THERE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD
BE. BUT THE GOVERNOR JUST
ANNOUNCED THE CALIFORNIA
CONNECTED PROGRAM. SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT CONTACT TRACING. WE ARE
FOLLOWING COUNTIES I'VE BEEN ON
THE STATE WHO ARE USING
TECHNOLOGY TO ENCOURAGE
EMPLOYERS TO REPORT HEALTH DATA
REGARDING THEIR EMPLOYEES. ALL
IN THE NAME OF STOPPING THE
SPREAD OF HOPE IT. BUT I WONDER
IF CPR A WITH A LOT OF THE WAY
ON. WITH THIS PROHIBITS SOME OF
THESE CRITICAL ACTIONS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS.
TODAY WERE KEENLY AWARE IN THE
AWARE HER WORLD CAN CHANGE
OVERNIGHT. WALKING INTO THE
CAPITAL TODAY I WAS STRUCK I
HAVE NOT SEEN STORES BOARDED
ACT WE HAVE NOT EXPERIENCED
ANYTHING IN OUR HISTORY WHAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED THE PAST FOUR
MONTHS. AND I WONDER. WE HAVE
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE OUR
LIVES AND OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BE AMENABLE AN
ADAPTABLE TO HELP US RESPOND.
WE NEED TO HAVE THE ABILITY OF
OUR LIKE DID OFFICIALS TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES.
UNFORTUNATELY CPR A SIMPLY
DOESN'T ALLOW FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN. EVEN IF A 100% OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND OUR GOVERNOR.
READ. THE OTHER ISSUE THAT'S A
CONCERN IS THE CREATION OF WHAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT OF THE NEW
STATE AGENCY. AGAIN AT A TIME
WHERE HE'S FACING PAINFUL
BUDGET CUTS TO SCHOOLS AND
HEALTH CARE. SHOULD WE REALLY
NOW CREATE A NEW AGENCY AND THE
NUMEROUS WILL MAKING TO PART MY
CPR EIGHT. AS A MOM OF TWO
CHILDREN IN PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM I WANT MY KIDS BACK IN
THE CLASSROOM. SHOULD MONEY BE
SPENT THEY'RE NOT I'M MORE
GOVERNMENTAGENCIES ON THIS IT
INITIATIVE. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COST TO COMPLY. OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS ESSENTIAL
RETAILERS STOOD UP THEY KEPT
THEIR DOORS OPEN THEY ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR MEDICATIONS TO THE
GROCERIES THAT THEY NEEDED. NOT
A CENTURY THERE'S ARE JUST
OPENING. THEN YOU WERE SUPPOSED
TO OPEN LAST WEEKEND AND WERE
ABLE TO BECAUSE OF OTHER ISSUES
GOING ON IN THE STATE. SADLY
AND I'M SURE YOU'VE READ. THE
HEADLINES THERE WILL BE
RETAILERS THAT WILL NOT OPEN
THEIR DOORS IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
THOSE WHO DO. THERE RESOURCES
SHOULD BE SPENT PUTTING
CALIFORNIA'S BACK TO WORK
KEEPING THEIR POISON CUSTOMER
SAFE INSTEAD THIS INITIATIVE
PASSES WE'LL HAVE TO SPEND
MILLIONS ON COMPLIANCE AND
PRIVACY ATTORNEYS. FINALLY THE
OTHER ISSUES THE MORATORIUM ON
EMPLOYEE AND BUSINESS BUSINESS
INFORMATION. WHICH ON ITS FACE
SEEMS HELP ON THE INITIATIVE
BUT WE'RE ON CERTAIN WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE ABLE TO DO
ON THOSE ISSUES AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. YOUR HANDS MAY BE
TIED. ON REASONABLE MEASURES TO
PROTECT EMPLOYEE PRIVACY.
MISTER CHAIR. YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ON THIS. ON THIS IF YOU LAST
YEAR. WITH SO VITALLY
IMPORTANT. WE FULLY SUPPORT
YOUR CONTINUED WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. WE NEED ANOTHER
EXTENSION OF A SENSE THAT NOW.
THE INITIATIVE TO GOT TO
QUALIFY AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE MOOD WILL BE A VOTERS IN
NOVEMBER. FINALLY CZ PA JUST
WENT INTO A FACT. THE INK ON
THE ON THE REGULATIONS ISN'T
EVEN DRY. YET WE AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO GIVE THE TIME
FOR THIS POLICY FOR CCPA TO
WORK. IF THERE ARE DEFICIENCIES
LET'S WORK TOGETHER THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO FIX THAT.
WE ENCOURAGE YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES TO DO ALL YOU CAN DO
TAKE THIS OFF THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT AND PUSH IT TOWARDS
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. LET'S NOT LOCK IN AN
UNAVAILABLE OFF THAT IS
UNFATHOMABLE I THIS TIME IN OUR-
THE YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISSING. FOR YOUR TEST. ON
EXCEL IT'S TO LOWER CURTIS FROM
CA TI BELIEVE SHE ON THE LINE.
MISTER CURTIS SO YOU'LL
LIGHTING. YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER AND
MEMBERS OF THE MY IS FOR AND
I'M HERE ON THE OF THE CAN TECH
INTO THIRTY BLEEDING AT FOR THE
GLOBAL INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
YOUR STAFF FOR HOLDING THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS ON THE CPR A
INITIATIVE. TODAY I'D LIKE TO
TOUCH ON FOUR POINTS FIRST THE
BALLOT INITIATIVE AT COMPLEXITY
TO AN ALREADY COMPLEX LOT
BEFORE BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS
EVEN HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME FAMILIAR WITH THE EPA
REGULATIONS PROMULGATED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THE CITY
PA HAVEN'T EVEN GONE INTO
EFFECT YET. WELL THE AP CAN
BEGIN IMPORTANT FIFTY P. ON
JULY THE REGULATIONS WERE JUST
SENT OVER FROM THE EIGHTY TO
THE OFFICE OF MINISTRY TO LOG
ON TO FIRST IF THE ONLY A X.
REVIEW THE REGULAR. AT BY
EIGHTEEN COMPANY FOR OF WHAT
THAN AND FROM HAVE A SEEN THE
REGULATION AND FINAL CAP TO AND
THAT HOWEVER THE NUMBER PERCENT
POTENTIAL FOR MONTHS THE AGE
IMPORT OF THE EASY PAY. MOTOR
THINK HOW WILL VOTING ON TO
CHIU THE PER WE PRIDE LAWS. HI
IT SHOULD BE THE MAIN GOAL OF
ANY LAW. BUT CERTAINLY ONE THAT
IS AS COMPLEX AS A CITY PA. AND
NOW THE CPR A- THIRD THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE CREATE THE NEW
IMPORTANT AGENCY WHICH HAS NO
TRACK RECORD. THIS NEW AGENCY
THE CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
PROTECTION IT. WOULD ABSORB THE
RULE MAKING AUTHORITY GRANTED
UNDER THE ACT. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE. IF ADOPTED BY
CALIFORNIA VOTERS NEWMAN
MODIFIED OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE
CPR A WOULD NOT ENTER INTO
FORCE UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THIS IS THE EIGHTY WOULD
HAVE SEVERAL YEARS AT THE HELM
BEFORE THE NEW AGENCY TAKES
OVER. THE AG SHOULD NOT BE THE
PLANET ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
WILL BE DETRIMENTAL TO. NUMBERS
AND THE- HIGHER LEAN. TO GET UP
TO SPEED CONSIDERING THE AGES
AT THE MOMENT THUS FAR.
ADDITIONALLY THE CREATION OF A
NEW AGENT IS A VERY COSTLY
STATE. FINISHED PART FIVE
DOLLAR. AND REFINE. FIRST YEAR
AND THEN. CURRENTLY BEING
BECAUSE OF KOBE DISTRICT OR
EVEN MORE CONCERNED WITH IS A
ESPECIALLY GIVEN LIMITS THE
INITIATIVE AMENDED BILL WHICH
IS MY LAST POINT THE INITIAL
ONLY A ALLEGE TO ACTIVE IT
BETTER PRIVACY OR THAN
FURTHERANCE OF THE PURPOSE
INTENT OF THE LAW IS. THAT ME
BIOLAGE WITH THE- FOR STATE TO
BE HEARD BUT BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF AMEND ABILITY BUILT
INTO THIS INITIATIVE. THE
LEGISLATURE WILL NOT HAVE FULL
DISCRETION TO MAKE THE CHANGES
TO THE LAW. IT COVERT HAS
TAUGHT US ANYTHING IT'S THAT
EVERYTHING IS UNPREDICTABLE
THIS INITIATIVE WILL STRONG ARM
THE LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
DO. THINGS BEST AS IT RELATES
TO PRIVACY EVEN IN TIMES OF
CRISIS. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY AND
DISCUSS THE CONCERNS CONST PUMP
YEAH AND IF MEMBERS HAVE WITH
THIS INITIATIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IS CURTIS- NEXT SO WE
HAVE MISTER SHOW UP- MOHAMMED
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE MISTER MOHAMMED ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. I AM. PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
ALSO. THANK YOU RESPECTED TURN
MEMBERS- FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HEARD AN INTERESTED PARTY
IN THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
CPR A- AND FOR YOUR CONTINUED
MEETING FOR WORK ON THIS ISSUE-
MY NAME IS TWELVE MOHAMMED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND BEFORE IT BEGAN
ONE OF THE HIGHLIGHTS FOR ALL
PART TODAY THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER CALL THE- IN A VISIT.
ENGINE FIFTY AUTHORED WITH THE
COMMUNITY DURING THE TAKEN
ARKANSAS ABOUT THEIR WORK AMEND
MADE TO LANGUAGE OF OUR QUEST
WHICH WE DO SINCERELY
APPRECIATE BUT THERE WERE
SEVERAL PROVISIONS THAT WERE
NOT AMENDED- AND WHICH WE
BELIEVE WILL ADD TO THE COST
BECAUSE BUSINESS ARE ALREADY
FACING CAUGHT YOUR COMPLIANCE
WITH YOU CAN BE A AND- THOSE
CALL ARE FURTHER AG BY THE-
HARDSHIP BROUGHT UPON BY KOBE
NINETEEN DELUDED WORK. INCLUDED
CPR IN ADD TO THE DEATH THAT
ARE FACING HERE ON A BROADER
AND SO I SINCE ACOSTA WILL
SPEAK TO HOW COME YOUR BECAUSE
OF BY WHAT AROUND TO SEE CAN
FIND IT TWO YEARS. CALIFORNIA
SPENT. ON. LEGAL STATE IT TOOK
A THIS JANUARY BUSINESS IS A
VENTURE PLANTATION THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S REGULAR WERE NO FILED
WITH OIL MONDAY ON YOUR ARE YOU
YEAH TO BE ENFORCED LAW SO IN A
THE AND I MISSED DIFFERENT THAT
THE FACE IN THIS KIND OF
BUSINESS IS A REPURPOSE AVAIL
RESOURCE TOWARDS COST OF LEGAL
COME WITH A YEARS RIGHT. AND I
DISCUSSED THE S. R. I. ANY BY
BOB THE GENERAL TO ME THE TO
COST OF INITIAL CALL WITH SIX
FOR FIVE AND WHILE ALL ARE
BELIEVED WANT TO A MORE I NOW
OF THE COST THE FACT STILL
REMAINS THERE IS A CO. NOW NOW
NOW THAT. AND WHILE. TO ACHIEVE
COME WITH EACH YET BUSINESS
DONALD HAVE TO BEGIN BUILDING
COMPLIANCE WITH AN ANTI NEW
THAT WILL THE CPA AND BE READY
FOR IT TO TAKE A BUT TWENTY
THREE HOW MANY BILLS THE
COMPLIANCE BURDENS WITH YOU CAN
REQUIRE SIGNET CHANGE TO
INTERNAL TRAIN AND IN RECURRING
COSTS TO MANAGE AND I. AND THE
CPO A WALL SIMILAR IS
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FROM THE SIX
AND THE IF YOU REGULATE AND
WOULD WORK YET ANOTHER ROUND
COST BUT THE WITH THOSE
COMPLIANCE EFFORTS OUT FURTHER
BECAUSE SEVERAL OF THE NEW
PROVISIONS OF PEOPLE TO CARRY
THEIR SO SIGNIFICANT FROM STEVE
PA THE AGES READ WE BE TO BE RE
WRITTEN BUT THIS TIME BY NEW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY THIS WOULD
ANOTHER ROUND OF RULE MAKING
BOMB AND OTHER ROUND OF
UNCERTAINTY WELL THE- BOTH. ARE
IT WAS HE- A COP MOVING. I NEED
TO MAKE OUR CALL TO HIGHLIGHT
AMPLE EPRA WILL BUT TO THE MAY
IN WHICH THEY WRITE ENFORCED
WITH ONE ANOTHER. IT'S REQUIRED
THAT THIS IS QUICK SEARCH
PROVISIONS IN THEIR GRAY WITH
CON. AND SERVICE WITH INCLUDING
THE NEGOTIABLE CON. THE
REQUIRED COMPANIES TO MONITOR
ONE ANOTHER YEAH. THESE WERE
FOR REQUIRE LEGAL FEES AND
CONTRA BECAUSE SHE THAT BECAUSE
IF YOU'RE A CHANGES NUMBER
NEGOTIABLE ANY OF CERTAIN LIVE
BILL. BUSINESSES CAN OFF EXPECT
THE NEED ADJUST THE BUSINESS BY.
AND PROFIT FOR TOOK FOR THE IN.
AND LIVE SO WITH THESE YOU CAN
REQUIREMENTS AND TAKE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE. CREATE A NEW CATEGORY
OF PURSUANT TO ON A SENSITIVE
ONE. WHICH IS REGULATED IN A
MANNER DIFFERENT THAN PERSONAL
INFORMATION THE FIRST REQUIRES
BUSINESSES TO TREAT- P. I. N.
S. P. I HAVE SEPARATE
CATEGORIES OF INFORMATION. THAT
CREATES ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON
BUSINESSES ARE REQUIRING THEM
TO CREATE PROCESSES AND SYSTEMS
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO
IDENTIFY AND SEPARATE THOSE TWO
TYPES OF INFORMATION AND THE-
EARLY STORM CATEGORIZE THAT
INFORMATION. AND THE STOCKS ARE
OF COURSE TIME CONSUMING
TEDIOUS AND COSTLY SO IN SOME-
WE JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THE
CHANGES TO HELP PROVIDE SOME
UNDERSTANDING OF- WHY
COMPLIANCE YOUR DOES COME AT A
COST. THANK YOU AGAIN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
BURDENS DISCUSSION WE
APPRECIATE THIS COULD BE
SHOPPERS APPROACH TO THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH%
MISTER MUHAMMAD FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY FIND OUT MR THANK
GOD. FROM THE NOT FEDERATION OF
IN THIS IS. A BILL HE HERE
PHYSICAL. WELCOME IN YOU FOR
YOUR- YEAH THANKS VERY MISTER
CHAIR A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND TO THE COMMITTEE I
AM JOHN CAP TECH I AM SERVING
AS THE STATE DIRECTOR THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF AND IT
THIS THE NFIB- IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS IS
REPRESENTED BY THE NFIB. AND
I'M OR ALSO PART OF A COALITION
OF OTHER LEADING SMALL AND
ETHNIC BUSINESS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE WE HAVE NUMEROUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
RIGHTS ACT. OF ALL THE INITIAL
WILL IMPOSE ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY AND PERSONAL. MY
BUSINESSES FAR TOO OF WHICH
RIGHT NOW AS WE ALL KNOW ARE
NOT SURE OF THEIR SURVIVAL
PROSPECTS. SECOND IT
ESTABLISHES A NEW GOVERNMENT
AGENCY AT THE TIME WHEN THE
STATE IS FACING A CRASHING BUT
DEFICIT. AND THIRD IT LIMITS
THE LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
MAKE MEANINGFUL AMENDMENTS EVEN
WHEN PROBLEMS BECOME APPARENT.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
OPERATORS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING PERSON
CUSTOMERS PERSONAL INFORMATION.
NOBODY WANTS TO MAKE HAVE THEIR
INFORMATION GET INTO THE WRONG
HANDS. SINCE THE CCPA IN
SUBSEQUENT N. AND IT'S A PASSED
OUR MEMBERS AND MANY OTHER
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
SHOULDERING THE COSTLY BURDEN
OF IMPLEMENTING THE
TECHNOLOGICAL AND OPERATIONAL
MEASURES. NECESSARY TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW. ALSO AT THE
BUSINESSES ARE DOING THEIR BEST
RIGHT NOW TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE FINAL REGULATIONS MADE
AVAILABLE ABOUT A WEEK AGO A
LITTLE OVER A WEEK AGO. FOR IN
PERSON AT GAINES JUST TWO WEEKS
FROM NOW. BUT THERE IS MASSIVE
CONFUSION ABOUT THE LAW
REGULATIONS AND THE MEASURES
THAT NEED TO BE TAKEN TO
COMPLY. AND MANY FRANKLY SIMPLY
AREN'T EVEN FOCUSED ON THAT
RIGHT NOW THANKS TO THE
DEMOCRATS THIS. THEY'RE JUST
TRYING TO OUT HOW TO NAVIGATE
THE FEDERAL LOAN PROCESS AND
FRANKLY OTHER WORKPLACE RULES
TO GET THEIR LIGHTS TURNED.
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. THE COST
OF THE SEAT. ON THE TREMENDOUS.
THE SECOND THAT AS HIS MADE OUT
PREPARE. FOR THE ATTORNEY ROSE
UP TO MAKE THE OVERALL COMPLAIN
COSTS TO THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. AT ABOUT.
DOLLARS BUT FOR WHAT ENGINE IS
THE- IN A SMALL BIT IS ABOUT
THE THOUSAND DOLLARS. MEAN MANY
OF THESE BIG HAVE BEEN
SHATTERED SINCE MARCH AND MANY
REMAIN BOARDED UP TO THIS DAY.
PASSAGE OF THE C. C. C. PUPPY
ARE A WILL REQUIRE BUSINESS
OWNERS TO REVISE THEIR PRIVACY
PROGRAMS ONCE AGAIN AND TAKE ON
NEW UNFORESEEN COST. THIS
MEASURE ALSO PROPOSES
ESTABLISHING AS IT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED A NEW ENFORCEMENT
DEPARTMENT. NOW PROPONENTS MAY
CLAIM THAT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
BUT BUSINESS OWNERS AND
TAXPAYERS ARE GOING TO BE ASKED
TO FOOT THE BILL. FOR THE
BUDGET SHORTFALL FOR MANY
YEARS- AND- TO PREPARE TO
PROPOSE ANY NEW GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM OR AGENCY IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE SERIOUS ECONOMIC CRISIS
WHEN THE STATE IS CONSIDERING
ASSIVE CUTS AS YOU POINTED OUT
MISTER CHAIRMAN TO ME GETTING
THAT PROGRAMS. IS ONLY IN A-
AND HIGHLY INSENSITIVE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE IN
BUSINESSES PARTICULARS. AND FOR
IF WE'VE LEARNED ANY THROUGH
THE CCPA EXPERIENCE IT'S THAT
THESE LAWS REQUIRE IMMENSE
THOUGHT CONSIDERATION AND AN
ENTIRE ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE
SESSION TO MAKE THEM WORKABLE.
IF THE LAW GOES TO THE BALLOT
AND PASSES THIS INITIATIVE IN
MANY WAYS IS GOING TO TIE THE
HANDS OF THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE. WE BELIEVE THAT
MOST PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PRIVACY POLICY
REALIZE THAT LIMITING THE
LEGISLATURE'S PART OF POWER TO
AMEND THE LAW WILL BE
PROBLEMATIC. LOSING GIVEN THE
GO WITH- BRING THE COVE IN
NINETEEN CRISIS AND ITS IMPACT
ON SMALL BUSINESS AND THE FACT
THAT THE FINAL REGULATIONS FOR
THE ORIGINAL PRIVACY LAW HAVE
YET TO TAKE EFFECT. WE ARE
SIMPLY ASKING FOR MORE TIME FOR
THIS MEASURE. AS AS EVEN THE
SPONSOR HAS REALIZED THE
DISRUPTION OF KOBE NINETEEN IN
HIS OWN FILING PROCESS. SO WE
GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
FURTHER AVOID KIRK NEAL FURTHER
COLLATERAL DAMAGE ON OUR NUMBER
ONE JOB CREATORS SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS TRYING TO CRAWL OUT OF
THE HOLE. RIGHT NOW DURING A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME AND TO
RECOVER. THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
CANNOT AFFORD ADDITIONAL COST
OR CONFUSION AS THE STATE
BEGINS TO RE OPEN OUR FOR THE
CON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY. UP I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PANELISTS%
WHO HAVE TESTIFIED. FOR US
TODAY AND SOCIAL DISTANCING
HAS. TRULY MADE THIS PROCESS A
LOT MORE LOCAL AND WE OF.
SERVICE THE POPE. FOR I OPEN.
QUESTION TO A QUESTION IS FOR
CANNOT. I LIKE TO ASK YOU ANY
WHO. TO CALL IN FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT TO DIAL IN NOW. AND
THERE CAN BE A DELAY WITH THE
PHONE LINES AND CALLING IN
EARLY WILL HELP THE PROCESS GO
SMOOTHLY. AND AGAIN THE NUMBER
TO CALL IN IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR. TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS OR AS WELL AS ON YOUR
TV SCREEN. I LIKE TO- START OFF
WITH A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THAT
MAY BE THE FIRST ONE I'D LIKE
TO DIRECT TO THE- CONSUMER
OBVIOUS- ADVOCACY
REPRESENTATIVES. OF THE
INITIATIVE INCLUDES SECURITY
AND INTEGRITY WITHIN THE
DEFINITION OF BUSINESS PURPOSE.
TO INCLUDE THE ABILITY OF A
BUSINESS. TO ENSURE THE
PHYSICAL SAFETY OF NATURAL
PERSONS. NOW HISTORICALLY
SAFETY AND SECURITY HAVE BEEN
USED AS A AS JUSTIFICATIONS FOR
INVASIVE SURVEILLANCE OF
INDIVIDUALS. ENSURING PHYSICAL
SAFETY COULD BE CONSTRUED TO
INCLUDE THE COLLECTION OF
HIGHLY PERSONAL INFORMATION
SUCH AS YOUR LOCATION AND
PERSONAL COMMUNICATIONS EVEN
WHEN THOSE ARE NOT ESSENTIAL TO
THE OPERATIONAL PURPOSES OF THE
BUSINESS. THE QUESTION IS DO
YOU SEE THE ABILITY TO COLLECT
PERSONAL INFORMATION TO ENSURE
THE PHYSICAL SAFETY OF NATURAL
PERSONS IN THIS MEASURE BEING
USED IN A WAY THAT WILL
COMPROMISE INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY.
CONSUMERS WAITING ON THIS ISSUE
SO I'M SURE. YOU'RE FREE TO DO
SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES IT'S
HARD TO COORDINATE REMOTELY-
I'M SORRY ALEX COMMONSENSE.
EIGHT I DON'T KNOW THAT WE RE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED- ARE
MOST CONCERNED WITH ENSURING
PHYSICAL SAFETY OF NATURAL
PERSON THOUGH ALL OF THESE
EXCEPTIONS COULD BE READ
PROBABLY BYCOMPANIES WERE ALL
TURNED. OUT OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE DEATH SUCH AS DETECT
SECURITY INCIDENTS RESISTING
MALICIOUS DECEPTIVE FRAUDULENT
PROSECUTING PEOPLE ON THESE CAN
HAVE ALL BEEN VERY BROADLY
INTERPRETED BY BUSINESSES IN
THE PAST AND THAT IT'S HARD FOR
ANYONE TO CHALLENGE A BUSINESS
THAT THEY CLAIM NOT SORT OF
EXCEPTION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CHIME IN AWESOME AS WELL
MAHONEY. FINE ALL RIGHT THE
NEXT QUESTION I LIKE TO DIRECT
TO THE INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES- ANY OF THE
FOUR INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE
INVITED TO RESPOND. THE
PROPOSED INITIATIVE INITIALLY
TASK THE AG WOULD PROMULGATING
REGULATIONS UNTIL THE PROPOSED
AGENCY HAS INDICATED ITS
CAPACITY TO TAKE OVER THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. IS THERE A RISK
THAT REGULATIONS DEVELOPED BY
THE AG MAY NOT BE SUITABLE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OR ENFORCEMENT
BY THE AGENCY. FOLLOW UP CAN
BUSINESSES BE CONFIDENT THAT
REGULATIONS CREATED BY THE AG
WILL BE HONOR BY AND CONSISTENT
WITH THOSE CREATED BY THE
AGENCY. COULD UNCERTAINTY OVER
THIS TRANSITION BE PROBLEMATIC.
FOR THE ABILITY OF BUSINESSES
TO COMPLY WITH THE MEASURE I
KNOW IT'S A LONG QUESTION I SO
LET ME REPEAT THAT QUESTION.
THE PROPOSED INITIATIVE
INITIALLY TOSSED AG WITH
PROMULGATINGREGULATIONS UNTIL
THE PROPOSED AGENCY HAS
INDICATED ITS CAPACITY TO TAKE
OVER THAT RESPONSIBILITY. IS
THERE A RISK THAT REGULATIONS
DEVELOP IDG MAY NOT BE SUITABLE
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OR THE
ENFORCEMENT BY THE AGENCY.
FOLLOW UP QUESTION CAN
BUSINESSES BE CONFIDENT THAT
REGULATIONS CREATED BY THE AG
WILL BE HONORED BY AND
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE CREATED
BY THE AGENCY AND FINALLY.
COULD UNCERTAINTY OVER THIS
TRANSITION BE PROBLEMATIC. FOR
THE ABILITY OF BUSINESSES TO
COMPLY WITH THE MEASURE. SO ANY
PART OF THE- QUESTIONS FEEL
FREE TO CHIME IN A WITH YOU
HAVE A RESPONSE. AT RETAIL
MICHELIN WITH THE RETAILERS I
THINK THAT FROM A RETAIL
PERSPECTIVE OUR MEMBERS ARE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR CLARITY THEY
WANT TO KNOW WHY. WHAT ARE THE
PARAMETERS THAT THEY NEED TO DO
THEIR BUSINESS AND PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT COMES TO PRIVACY SO I
THINK IN LOOKING BACK ON THE
PROCESS THAT WE DID WITH AG
REGULATIONS THAT WAS A LONG
PROCESS I THINK WE STARTED IT
END OF LAST YEAR. AGAIN THAT
THE RAGS ONLY FINAL REX CAME
OUT BUT TWO WEEKS AGO. AT SO I
THINK THAT THERE IS I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU CAN GUARANTEE THAT
CONTINUITY WITH THE AGENCY THAT
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO WILL BE
PART OF THAT HELLO REALLY
FUNCTION. SO THERE BE AYE THE
BIGGEST CONCERN WOULD BE
OPENING UP TO LIABILITY I THINK
OPENING UP TO LAWSUITS AND
WE'VE ARE SEEN EVEN THE CPA L.
PEOPLE READY TO SUE
PARTICULARLY SMALLER BUSINESSES
THIS WAS JUST TRYING TO COMPLY.
AND I THINK EVERYTHING IS GOING
ON RIGHT NOW AGAIN THISWE
WOULD HAVE BEEN A MUCH
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION FOUR
MONTHS AGO. AND YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE WILL BE IN. THE
WAY TODAY. I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW. BEING ABLE GO EXACTLY
WHAT THE RULES ARE SO WEAK
COMPLY RETAILERS AND BUSINESS
IN GENERAL. THAT THE DOT FIRST.
I WOULD SEE SOME. TO HER AND
THEN TO TURN AND HAVE TO RE TO
NEW ELATION BECAUSE OF INITIAL
pI THINK IT BE DOCTOR TO A LOT
OF THESE IN OUR STATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO CHIME IN. IT ONLINE OR
IF PHYSICALLY HERE. MISTER CAP
THAT FOR FREE. THIS TERMINATE I
THINK THE REIGNING WORD HERE
THAT WE KEEP HEARING NOT JUST
AGAIN FROM THE INDUSTRY BUT
FROM SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE IS
UNCERTAINTY- LACK OF CLARITY-
AND WE'RE FINDING THAT RIGHT
NOW IN THIS SITUATION WITH CODE
AMONG SO MANY SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES
THERE CAN STEP CONSUMERS- SO
PEOPLE REALLY DON'T KNOW BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE MOST
COMPELLING THINGS WE I HEARD
THIS MORNING WAS IN THE
LEGISLATIVE AT- REPRESENT WHO
SAID EIGHT. THE TOTAL IMPACT OF
THIS AUDIT THIS PROPOSAL ALONE
THIS NEW ONE IS UNKNOWN AND SHE
ALSO SAID IT WAS UNCLEAR HOW
BUSINESSES WILL ADJUST SO AGAIN
EVEN THE LEGISLATIVE THE NON
PARTISAN LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
IS TALKING ABOUT THE LACK OF
CLARITY AND UNCERTAINTY AS WE
LOOK AHEAD IF PEOPLE WILL IT
THAT'S WHAT THE COSTS WILL BE
AND THAT'S ABOUT THE NEW
PROPOSAL THIS HAS YET TO GO
INTO EFFECT- AND NOT EVEN THE
FIRST THEN THE FIRST WILL BE
ORIGINAL CCPA WHICH WE HAVEN'T
SEEN. YET SO THE WHAT THE WORD
UNCERTAINTY COMES INTO QUESTION
QUITE A BIT I MEAN IT IS A BIG
TURN WITH US RIGHT NOW IS
NOBODY REALLY UNDER AND KNOWS
ISN'T ALREADY LIVING IN A FULL
TIME RIGHT NOW WE WANT TO AND
THAT CONTRACT SO THE FEED THE
ACCOUNT. JOBS BUT THE BACK OF
CERTAINTY IS SOMETHING LA. SO
MANY. AND THAT'S ANY RIGHT NOW
SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE- BECAUSE-
AS THIS IS THIS IS CONSIDERED.
THANK YOU. THANK VERY MUCH
ANYBODY ON THE LINE LIKE TO
THAT. PART OF THE. HEARING NONE
LEFT SO- ASK A COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS SO THESE QUESTIONS
ARE FOR ANY PALESTINIAN OF THE
PALACE IN GENERAL FIRST
QUESTION CONSIDERING THE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
NECESSARY TO AMEND THE CONTENT
OF A BALLOT INITIATIVE AND THE
DYNAMIC NATURE OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY. WHAT MAKES A BALLOT
INITIATIVE RATHER THAN A
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION THE
APPROPRIATE MECHANISM FOR
REALIZING THE OBJECTIVES OF THE
PROPOSED INITIATIVE. THIS IS
FOR ANY OF THE PANELISTS. I
THINK. I AM JUST ONE THAT YOU
RESTATE MY PRIOR TESTIMONY THAT
AT THAT POINT IN TIME I DON'T
THINK THE BALLOT INITIATIVE IS
THE PROPER MECHANISM THAT I
THINK THAT WE BOUGHT THE IN HOW
COMPLICATED THE PROCESS AND
THAT IT SHOULD BE DONE THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE RATHER RENT
THROUGH THE BALLOT INITIATIVE
PROCESS. THANK YOU. MISS
MITCHELL EVERY TO MECHELEN
RETAILERS I AGREE WITH WHAT
THAT THE PREVIOUSLY I THINK
MERRY JUST SAD AND YOU KNOW WE
JUST WENT THROUGH A PROCESS I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE- WAS VERY
WISE IN PUSHING CCPA THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND I
THINK THAT PROCESS IS
IMPORTANT- ARE LEGISLATORS ARE
ELECTED OUR GOVERNOR IS
ELECTED. AND I THINK THAT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE GOOD DIALOGUE FROM
BOTH SIDES IN LAST YEAR THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF PRIVACY BILLS
THAT THAT WE'VE MADE A LOT OF
CONSENSUS ON WE WORKED ON AND
THEN AS WE WORKED WITH YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP. I JUST THINK THE
PROCESS FRIEND A GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY THE EMPLOYEE IS THE BEST
WAY TO GO THEY PUTTING IT IN A
BONTA BALLET WHERE. WE WILL SO
MANY OF THEM ON THE BALLOT.
CONSUMERS AND VOTERS MAY NOT
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT
THEY'RE VOTING FOR WHAT THEY'RE
NOT VOTINGFOR. THANK YOU. OKAY
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
CONSUMER REPORTS WERE NOT A
PRESCRIPTIVE ABOUT WHETHER NOT
ADVANCE ON PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
WOULD BE ACHIEVED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE OR THROUGH THE
BALLOT ONE THING WE DO
APPRECIATE ABOUT THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE IS IT WOULD INCLUDE
A PROVISION- THAT WOULD MAKE IT
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO FOR THE FOR THE
WEEKEND THE LAW. THIS BECAME
REALLY IMPORTANT IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN LEGISLATIVE SESSION
WHEN- RAFT OF BILLS WERE
INTRODUCED IN ORDER TO WEAKEN
THE CPA ALTHOUGH THE WORST OF
THE BILL'S MORE STOPS- YOU KNOW
THERE WERE LOOPHOLES THAT WERE
CREATED AND- ALL THE BILLS
INTRODUCED TO AND IMPROVE THE
MEASURE- IN TERMS OF PRIVACY
FAIL TO ADVANCE- SO WE THINK
THAT'S A AN ASPECT ABOUT THE
SHIFT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ON THE LINE TO RESPOND.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE OF AT
THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO- GIVE
MISTER MCTAGGART A CHANCE TO
PERHAPS RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
ISSUES RAISED- AND- AFTER A FEW
FEW MINUTES PRODUCT PERHAPS IF
YOU DON'T MIND- YOU KNOW I'LL
LET YOU MAKE A DECISION AS TO
WHICH ISSUE LIKE TOURIST
RESPONDED SHALL TO TRY TO GO
THROUGH SOME OF THEM IN ORDER.
SURE WITH RESPECT TO THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS COMBINING
DATE AND THAT BEING
INAPPROPRIATE WE DO HAVE A
REGULATION. ALL READ IT- ISSUE
REGULATIONS IDENTIFYING THOSE
BUSINESS PURPOSES. FOR WHICH
SERVICE WRITERS MAY USE
CONSUMERS P. I RECEIVE PURSUANT
TO RID CONTRA BUSINESS. FOR THE
FOR THE SERVICE WRITER THE
CONTRACTORS OWN BUSINESS
PURPOSE WITH THE GOAL OF
MAXIMIZING CONSUMER PRIVACY SO
WE DID THINK ABOUT THAT. WE
THINK WE'VE ADDRESSED IT BY
SPECIFIC REGULATION ASKING FOR
THAT. IN TERMS OF SABOTAGING
THE EXISTING LAW YOU KNOW I
HAVE TO KINDA LAUGHED BUT
THINKING THAT I WOULD SPEND A
LOT OF MONEY DOING THE FIRST
LAW. AND THEN WOULD CONSCIOUSLY
TRY TO SABOTAGE THE SECOND
ALMOST ANY MORE TIME AND MONEY
DOING IT. YOU KNOW IF THAT
CRITICISM IS THAT I TALKED TO
GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK EXPERIENCE
WELL GUILTY AS CHARGED I'LL TO
TALK TO EFF. WAS REYES CLEARING
HOUSE ACLU. COMMONSENSE THE
DOCTOR ACADEMICS THE DEAN OF
THE CAN THE BERKELEY LAW
SCHOOL. AB PROFESSES A BERKELEY
ORGANIZED BROWN TABLE FOR ME TO
TALK TO E. REGULATORS LKE THE
FEDERAL REGULATORS THE
PROFESSOR I MEAN I. CENTER
HERTZBERG AND I TALKED TO
EVERYBODY. IN FACT WE TALKED
BUSINESS ABSOLUTELY THERE
STAKEHOLDERS TO IN TERMS OF-
THE AGENCY BEING UNDER FUNDED
PAPER TIGER. YOU KNOW COMPARING
THE BUDGET OF TEN MILLION TO
THE FTC'S BUT IF YOUR NAME IS
DIRECTOR FRANK RIDICULOUS. THE
FTC HAS MANY MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND JUST
PRIVACY. THIS WOULD HAVE THE
SAME NUMBER OF PRIVACY
PROFESSIONALS RIGHT NOW IS THE
FD AS FTC HAS FOR THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. SO THAT'S THAT THAT'S
THE RIGHT- COMPARISON AS I SAID
BEFORE IF IT'S NOT ENOUGH. THE
LEGISLATURE IN ITS WISDOM CAN
VOTE MORE. THE ISSUE IS JUST
THAT THIS WOULD PREVENT IT FROM
BEING DEFINED OF LIKE GOVERNOR
BROWN DID IN TWENTY TWELVE. IN
TERMS OF LABOR UNIONS DO WE
HAVE TO SUPPORT ABSOLUTELY I
TALK TO SEAL S. YEAH YOU CAL
FED. THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY GOT
THEIR INPUT AND THEY SUPPORTED
THIS THREE YEAR- A WINDOW SO
CLEARLY- WITH CENTER HERTZBERG-
DISSIPATION WE TALKED ALL THE
NEWS AND KEPT THEM ON ON THE ON
SITE. TERMS UNDER MIND EIJI NO
WE'RE SIMPLY RE ASSIGNING THE
RULE MAKING AUTHORITY TO KEEP
THE SAME ROLE WORKING THIRTY.
ACTUALLY BROUGHT IN THAT BUT
GIVE IT TO A NEW AGENCY- TERMS
WITH OPTIONAL IT IS NO LOOPHOLE
WITH OPTIONAL IF THEY WANTED TO
EARLIER THERE IS NO OPTION
ALREADY. BUSINESSES HAVE TO
RESPECT WE DO NOT SELL SIGNAL
NO MATTER WHICH WAY THEY GO. IN
TERMS OF DE IDENTIFIED BEING A
LOOPHOLE MY GOODNESS I HAVE-
AGAIN US ABOUT- EMAIL CHAIN FOR
SUPPORT FROM YES. ACLU AND
COMMON- AND CONSUMER REPORTS
SIGNING OFF ON OUR DEFINITION
OF DE IDENTIFIED THE REASON HAD
TO BE CHANGED IS BECAUSE EXPERT
THAT LOOKED. BEST PRACTICE IN
DE IDENTIFIED IS THAT YOU THE
BUSINESS HAVE TO. ACTUALLY TEST
TO RE IDENTIFY WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE DOING A GOOD JOB. I
DIDN'T COME FROM ME. EXT AND
AGAIN IF YOU HAVE THREE OF THE
LEADING PRIVACY ORGANIZATIONS
APPROVING THE LANGUAGE IS HARD
FOR ME TO SAY THAT THAT IS A
GIVEAWAY TO BUSINESS. SO AND AS
WE WENT THROUGH AND IN IN GREAT
DETAIL I MEAN A LOT MORE THAN
SEVEN CHANGES FROM THE
ADVOCATES LETTER. IN TERMS OF-
RETAILERS- THE IT YOU KNOW I
THINK THE THING THAT TO REALIZE
ABOUT BOTH- CCPA AUNTS AND CPR
IT. IS BUSINESSES ARE ALLOWED
TO USE THEIR OWN INFORMATION TO
DATE THE SYMBOL ON THEIR
CUSTOMERS THAT'S AND THEIR
CONSUMERS THAT'S IT'S THE
SELLING PART THAT'S THAT THAT'S
THAT. WE DRAW THE LINE- AND SO.
NOW THEY'RE BE A NEW
RESTRICTION ON SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION BUT
PRESUMABLY RETAILERS ARE NOT
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. MY
RELIGION WHEN- THERE COULD
FIGURE OUT IF I WANT TO BUY A
BLUE TEE SHIRT OR A RED TEE
SHIRT- AND- AGAIN IN TERMS OF
BOTH. A LOT OF THE RETAILERS A
LOT OF THE BUSINESS FOLKS. WE
ARE VERY SENSITIVE TO TRYING TO
EASE THE BURDEN OF COMPLIANCE-
HERE AND PRESERVE PRIVACY. SO
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN TERMS OF THE- WHATEVER
THE NUMBER OF BUSINESSES THAT
ARE COVERED BY CCPA. PRESUMABLY
BY CLARIFYING THAT IF BUSINESS
IS THE JUST BUY AND SELL
INFORMATION AS OPPOSED TO.
RECEIVE OR SHARE FOR COMMERCIAL
PURPOSE. AND BY REVERTING TO
THE TWENTY REGIONAL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DEFINITION OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PIECE OF
INFORMATION HERE. WERE REALLY
SAYING. AGAIN JUST TO CLARIFY
THE SMALL MOAN POPS WHERE
THAT'S NOT THE PROBLEM. BUT
THEY'RE NOT COVERED. AND IF
THEY'RE SELLING INFORMATION IS
A DIFFERENTPROVISION THE
CATCHES THEM SO IT'S SORT LONG
AS OUR SMALL- BUSINESS WE
REALLY- REDUCE THE COMPLIANCE
BURDEN ON THE SMALL BUSINESS-
EMPLOYEE PRIVACY THAT CAME UP.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE WHERE WE SAID
LOOK RETURN THAT OVER THE
LEGISLATURE THAT'S COMPLICATED
SO IF THIS PASSES YOU'LL HAVE
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
SORT OUT THAT- AND AGAIN THAT
WAS WITH THE FULL INPUT OF
LABOR. HUMAN TALK TO LABOR-
USUALLY. IN TURN OF- YOU KNOW
THE EDITION OF REGULATIONS. ALL
I WOULD SAY IS IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU KNOW ONCE THE CAR AND ONE'S
A BOAT. CBRE BUILDS ON CCPA SO
THE WORK THE PEOPLE ARE PUTTING
IN PLACE FOR CPA WILL NOT BE
LOST. AND AT THE MARGIN THE
NUMBER OF NEW REGULATIONS GOING
TO AFFECT ARE NOT GOING TO BE
NEARLY. AS SUBSTANTIAL AS GOING
FROM NOTHING TO WHERE WE ARE
NOW SO- AGAIN WE WERE SENSITIVE
TO- IMPLEMENTATION THAT'S BEEN
PART OF OUR PROCESS ALL LONG
STRIDE IMPROVE WORKABILITY.
WHILE TRYING TO PRESERVE
PRIVACY AND I THINK WE'VE DONE
A GOOD JOB ON ON THAT HERE-
AND- YOU KNOW I THINK AGAIN
LIKE TO SENSITIVE INFORMATION
CAME UP. WE HAVE A PROVISION
HERE SAYING IF YOU'RE NOT
COLLECT. INFORMATION AND USING
IT AS IT'S AN FROM IT DOESN'T.
IT'S NOT COVERED ASSN. TRYING
BE REALLY FOR. ABOUT THE MATH.
EFFECT LAW. THE PRESERVES AND
CONSUMER FOR TO THEM MOST UP.
AND ALSO HAS THE EASIEST
COMPLAINTS. BECAUSE AGAIN A
GOOD LAWS WHEN THAT WILL BE YOU
KNOW EASY IMPLEMENT SO- I AM
I'M I'M- THANKS FOR ALL THE
COMMENTS TODAY BUT- AND THEN
FINALLY ON AS TO WHETHER
INITIATIVE IS THE RIGHT
VEHICLE. I'VE BEEN OVER THAT I
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT TIME FOR
THAT RIGHT NOW BUT SOME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN- IN FIFTY
TWO MY COLLEAGUES THERE. YEAH
WELL AS ALL THE PANELISTS SO I
LIKE TO TURN TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS TIME- IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE- ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. LIKE
TO INVITE YOU TO COME ON UP BUT
IF YOU DO SO. SEEING AND
HEARING NOW LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES SO. ANYONE ON THE
LINE. WISHING TO. SPEAK IN
PUBLIC COMMENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN A COMMENT ON THE INITIATIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. USING A SPEAKER
PHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON THE
INITIATIVE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
NINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS EMORY RUNG REPRESENTING
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARING HOUSE
IN SAN DIEGO THE CONSUMER
PRIVACY ADVOCATES BEING
IN THE ISSUE SPACE FOR MORE
THAN TWO DECADES. IS THE STATE
IN THE CITY ARE YOU A IS A
MIXED BAG IN SOME WAYS GOING
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAS WILLING TO DO
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND IN
TWENTY TWENTY. BY IMPROVING THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY ACT IN SOME
KEY AREAS. IN SOME CASES
ADOPTING VARIATIONS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WE'VE MADE IN
RECENT YEARS INCLUDING THE
REMOVAL OF THE STATUTORY RIGHT
TO CURE OF THE CCPA AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION DEFINITIONS.
HOWEVER IN ADDITION TO THE
ISSUES RAISED BY OUR COLLEAGUES
AT CONSUMER REPORTS AND COMMON
SENSE MEDIA. WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT IN OTHER AREAS THE C. D.
R. E. A. REPRESENTS ONLY HALF
STEPS THE REASON THE STEPS. THE
DATA MINIMIZATION REQUIREMENTS
WHICH PERMITTED BUSINESS TO
COLLECT AND PROCESS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OT NECESSARY FOR
THE PURPOSES FOR WHICH THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION WAS
COLLECTED. AS LONG JUST USE FOR
ANOTHER DISCLOSE PURPOSE AND IS
COMPATIBLE WITH THE CONTEXT
WITH WHICH INFORMATION WAS
COLLECTED. WE THINK IT WOULD DO
LITTLE TO PREVENT FOR EXAMPLE
OF CONTACT TRACING APPLICATION
FROM INCLUDING EXPLICATED
LANGUAGE BURIED IN THAT THIS IS
JUST CRIED SHE POLICY. SO LONG
AS THE DISTANCE CAN MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT IS BEEN
TECHNICALLY DISCLOSED AND IS
COMPATIBLE WITH THE INITIAL
COLLECTION AND USE. IT ALSO
REMAINS UNCLEAR WHAT IMPACT
INITIATIVES AMENDMENTS
SECTIONAL HAVE ON THE BILL
WOULD BE TO IMPROVE AND REMEDY
THE ISSUES WE SEE IN THE C. P.
R. YEAH LIKE. OR THE IMPACT
IT'LL HAPPEN TEACHER PRIVACY
LEGISLATION. WE WOULD HAVE
PREFERRED TO SEE THESE. BY YOUR
PIECE OF WHAT. PERHAPS AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY AND TWENTY
NINETEEN OR A. B. THIRTY ONE
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY.
COULDN'T MOVE FORWARD REAL
ALTERNATIVES TO THE SOLUTION
PROPOSED IN THE C. P. R. EA.
HOWEVER THIS TIME WILL BE
NEITHER SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING.
INITIATIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR FOR YOUR CALL-
ANYONE ELSE SO. WHO WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. AT NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WE LIKE TO GO
AHEAD WE LIKE TO ASK YOUR
COMMENT TO BE BRIEF IF POSSIBLE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR DON'T HAVE. THANK
YOU. I DON'T OFTEN ON BEHALF OF
INTERNET ASSOCIATION- I'D LIKE
TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM CAL CHAMBER
CANTIERE NFIB. AND CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS EXPECTATION. ALSO
LIKE TO REITERATE THAT I AND
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES ARE
COMMITTED POLICIES THAT PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS MEANINGFUL CONTROL
OVER THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION. INCLUDING THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS CORRECT
DELETE AND DOWNLOAD DATA THEY
PROVIDE THE COMPANIES. ARE
CURRENTLY OUR MEMBERS ARE
FOCUSED ON IMPLEMENTATION IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE PPA AS WELL
THE ON GOING REGULATORY
PROCESS. BUT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. HELLO WE ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT THE-
INITIATIVE WILL UP AND NOT
PROCESS AND AT THE CHALLENGES
TO MANY THE ACT WILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES GOING FORWARD. I A
AND OUR MEMBERS LEAVE NOW AS WE
GET THE TCPA THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THE PROPER VENUE TO
BAT SUCH A COMPLEX AND
TECHNICAL AREA OF LAW AND
POLICY IF PASSED. WE BELIEVE
THIS INITIATIVE BUT EFFECTIVELY
SIDELINED LEGISLATURE. NOT ONLY
BAD IN THE POLICY RATES BY THE
NATIONAL BUT ALSO IN ADAPTING
WHAT OF THE NEW TECH. AND
CIRCUMSTANCE IN THE FUTURE WE
GREATLY THE BUILDING AWAY AND
THAT'S- LICCARDO. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON NOT DEPRIVE AND
SECURITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CALL SIR OUT DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE. YES MY
NAME THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ADD THIS IS COURTNEY
JUNK THENWAY ON BEHALF OF TAX
THAT I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES ON THAT MEMBER
COMPANIES PLACE A HIGH PRIORITY
ON CONSUMER PRIVACY AND
COMPANIES ARE STILL WORKING
THROUGH COMPLIANCE WITH THE CPA
GIVING REGULATIONS ARE NOT YET
FINAL. NOW THE CPR A WOULD
REQUIRE COMPANIES TO REDUCE THE
FACT THAT THEY JUST CREATED BY
WITH THE CCPA MOVING TARGET
COMES AT A HUGE COST FOR
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES INCLUDING
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES WE'RE
TRYING TO RECOVER AND GROW JOBS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE AMEND
ABILITY SECTION AT THE PIER AND
BELIEVE THAT ACTION HI THE
HANDS OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
REACT THE EVOLUTION AND
TECHNOLOGY AND DEAL WITH URGENT
ISSUES NOT BEAT YOUR THAT MAY
HAVE SOME PRIVACY ELEMENT. LAWS
NEED TO BE AMENABLE AND
ADAPTABLE AND THROUGH THE AREA
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR THIS I DO
HAVE ALSO HEARD CPR A
REPLACEMENT AG'S OFFICE AS THE
REGULATOR AND CREATE THE NEW
AGENCY WHICH WILL PUT
ADDITIONAL BUDGET PRESSURE ON
AN ALREADY STRAINED BUDGET. IF
THE BALLOT MEASURE WERE TO PASS
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND MONEY WOULD BE TAKEN FROM
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET FOR THIS NEW AGENCY
AT A TIME WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
IS MAKING HARD DECISIONS TO
COME TO A BALANCED BUDGET THIS
IS NOT THE RIGHT TIME I TO FORT
ST JOHN. I KNOW IT CAN'T BE OUR
APPRECIATE IT CARE FOR HOLDING
HEARING TODAY AND OUR- US TO
SPEAK THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CALL ANYONE. ELSE ON THE
LINE. THERE ARE NO FOR THE
COMMON IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU.
MADAM OPERATOR I LIKE TO THANK
BY OF THANKING MY IPHONE UP
MEMBERS AS WELL AS MR
MCTAGGART- MISLI AND ALL OF THE
PANELISTS WHO TESTIFIED TODAY.
AS I NOTED IN MY OPENING
PROVIDING VOTERS WITH.
INFORMATION GOING INTO
NOVEMBER'S SO ELECTION IS NOT
ONLY A STATUTORY OBLIGATION IT
IS ALSO AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
SERVICE. IT IS MY HOPE THAT THE
DEBATE AND DISCUSSION THAT TOOK
PLACE HERE TODAY. WILL LAY THE
GROUNDWORK OF FOR VOTERS TO
ENGAGE IN A THOUGHTFUL AND
METHODICAL CONSIDERATION OF THE
MERITS OF THIS PROPOSED
INITIATIVE. AND ALSO ENCOURAGE
INFORMED PARTICIPATION IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS THIS
NOVEMBER AND BEYOND. SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR BEING HERE- AND THIS WILL
CONCLUDE OUR HEARING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.